J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, il y a de ces invités dont le nom est sur ma lettre à Saint Nicolas depuis les origines de Septante Minutes Avec, il y a déjà cinq ans.
2019, c'était aussi une année électorale et à l'époque, j'avais été très heureux, je me souviens, d'avoir pu interviewer des noms respectés dans le journalisme politique.
Je pense par exemple à Alain Gerlache ou à Frédéric Chardon à l'époque. Mais déjà à ce moment-là, il y avait un troisième journaliste que je guettais, tapi dans l'ombre.
Et en fait, pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous, c'est tout à fait vrai, j'avais d'abord estimé que j'étais pas prêt et qu'il me fallait plus d'expérience pour l'interviewer.
Et aussi, je savais que je voulais l'avoir pendant une année électorale. Et c'est aujourd'hui, c'est maintenant, cher public, que les planètes sont alignées.
Alors, vous sentez que je suis absolument partial et que mon invité débarque en terrain conquis. Et c'est vrai, puisque je l'admets, j'aime et j'apprécie énormément son travail, son humour et l'étendue de sa culture.
Mais je vous rassure quand même, vous allez voir qu'on n'est pas forcément d'accord sur tout.
J'ai aussi fait arbitrairement le choix de ne pas nous concentrer sur les élections actuelles, mais plutôt de se permettre une rétrospective de manière à se rappeler ce qui aura marqué ces vingt dernières années en politique et qui façonne
indirectement la situation dans laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui.
Et non, on n'a pas parlé de Benjamin Maréchal. C'est parti pour Septante Minutes Avec Bertrand Henne. J'ai le plaisir, en exclusivité, de recevoir l'excellent Bertrand Henne. Bonjour Bertrand.
Bonjour.
Bertrand, donc tu es, faut-il le rappeler, journaliste politique à la RTBF et éditorialiste depuis vingt ans. Presque vingt ans.
Presque vingt et un.
Voilà, vingt ans et demi. Septembre, septembre 2003. Ce qui va nous permettre, du coup, de faire une rétrospective sur ces vingt ans.
On va pas tellement parler du contexte électoral actuel, même si j'imagine qu'il y aura de temps en temps des petits parallèles à faire, mais on va surtout, voilà, faire une rétrospective et parler de journalisme.
Et parler de toi aussi, puisque tu es assez discret, en fait, hein, dans les médias, on te voit pas si souvent.
Tu viens du PW, tu as fait les scouts, tu aimes la bière et c'est à peu près tout ce qu'on peut savoir de toi quand on fait des recherches, puisque quand on tape Bertrand Henne sur Google,
on tombe, comme je te le disais, sur des vidéos de toi et de Maudrick Amen, de toi et de Bart De Wever, ainsi de suite, ainsi de suite.
Mais finalement, on sait très peu de choses sur toi. À dix-huit ans, tu choisis d'aller étudier à l'école de journalisme à Louvain.
Et à vingt-trois ans, comme je le disais, tu choisis de rejoindre la RTBF.
Exactement, oui, oui, voilà. C'est normal qu'on trouve peu d'informations parce que je ne suis pas très friand de—
Tu es discret.
Oui, parce que—
Politique.
Parce que j'aime pas la starification des journalistes.
OK.
C'est un élément qui m'ennuie beaucoup, en particulier dans le paysage français, par exemple, qui est très friand de ça, même un peu dans le paysage politique belge.
Je trouve que c'est bien normal d'avoir un ego et d'avoir
de l'ambition, de faire entendre sa voix quand on est journaliste, mais il faut la faire entendre dans des reportages, dans des analyses, dans notre travail au jour le jour et pas tellement dans une mise en avant de soi.
Voilà. Après, ça me dérange pas d'en parler, par exemple ici, dans quelque chose qui est assez confidentiel ou des choses comme ça, mais...
Qu'est-ce que tu essaies de dire ?
Non, mais je le ferais pas, par exemple, voyez, pour des grands magazines. Je ne cherche pas ça. Je cherche pas la visibilité,
de mettre en avant ma biographie, mon effort personnel, mes propres mérites, mes choses comme ça.
Enfin, ce que je crois, le public attend de moi, c'est le travail que je fais au jour le jour. C'est pas d'en savoir plus, même si c'est pas grave.
Je comprends que ça peut intéresser. Mais voilà, moi, je recherche pas ça.
En effet, c'est pas le but. C'était surtout une intro. Mais du coup, voilà, tu choisis de t'inscrire en journalisme à Louvain.
Pourquoi en fait ? Qu'est-ce qui t'attire à ce stade dans ta vie vers le journalisme ?
Parce que je savais pas quoi faire.
C'est étrangement souvent la réponse que les gens me donnent.
Oui, mais c'est vrai. En fait, quand je suis sorti de mes études secondaires, je savais pas quoi faire non plus. Je crois que ça arrive à beaucoup de jeunes.
Pas de vocation, pas d'évidence, en tout cas. Voilà, il y a des choses que j'aimais bien faire. J'adorais lire, j'adorais regarder des documentaires, je suis curieux de manière générale, ça oui.
Et donc quand j'ai dû—
C'est une qualité nécessaire.
Oui, je pense. Indispensable, oui, sinon on ne fait pas ce métier-là. Ou alors, on le fait pour des très mauvaises raisons, comme par exemple son ego, parce qu'on a envie d'être visible.
Mais alors, on devient acteur. Autant devenir tout de suite acteur.
On reviendra là-dessus dans un instant.
Mais donc, j'étais curieux et déjà en choisissant mes études, je me suis dit : Tiens, je sais pas quoi faire. Et c'est en entendant un ami, j'hésitais, l'histoire, la sociologie, plutôt des sciences humaines, disons.
J'étais pas très fort en mathématiques et en sciences, même si ça m'intéresse. Et puis j'ai un ami qui m'a dit : Moi, je vais faire la philo.
Je dis : Tiens, la philo, c'est vrai, j'y ai jamais pensé. Je savais même pas que ça existait, des études de philo en Belgique.
Enfin, j'y avais jamais vraiment pensé, c'est ça que je voulais dire. Et puis je dis : Tiens, je vais essayer ça.
Et j'ai fait des études de philo, ça m'a directement plu. L'histoire des idées, les grands auteurs. J'ai commencé par ça.
J'ai fait cinq ans, ce que j'ai traîné sur les bancs. Et puis, à la fin de mes études de philo, il fallait quand même bien rendre ça concret dans un futur métier, parce que la philosophie, ça mène à tout, donc à rien.
Et je me suis dit : Bah pourquoi pas—
Pas forcément beaucoup de débouchés quand on a un master—
Voilà, pas précis quoi. Il faut rendre ça concret.
Mh.
Et puis alors je me suis dit : Tiens, pourquoi pas aller encore une année d'études et pourquoi pas le journalisme ? C'est vrai, j'avais ça peut-être dans un coin de ma tête, mais sans vraiment y penser en me rasant tous les matins.
C'est ça que je veux dire.
OK, OK.
Bon voilà.
Et c'est toujours—
J'ai testé ça.
Voilà, ce goût pour la philosophie, les auteurs que tu as connus—
Ah oui, oui, oui, oui.
Tu continues à t'instruire, si tu veux.
Oui, oui. J'adore ça. Je continue à lire presque tous les jours la philosophie, à écouter beaucoup de podcasts avec des philosophes—
Quel genre, par exemple ? Quel courant idéologique ? Quel courant de philosophie ?
En fait, j'aime tout. Je vais pas dire que j'aime tout en philo, mais presque. De temps en temps, je suis plus sur—
Tu peux lire Nietzsche comme tu peux lire—
Oui, oui, oui.
Platon ou...
Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Vraiment. Ce qui m'intéresse dans la philosophie, c'est l'histoire des idées. C'est-à-dire comment, pourquoi est-ce que à certaines époques, on a pensé comme ça.
Mh.
Et donc je lis de tout. Je lis des auteurs de droite, de gauche, de la philosophie politique, de la bioéthique, de... Tout m'intéresse.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est la pratique de la pensée. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pensé comme ça à certains moments dans l'histoire ?
Mh.
Comment est-ce que les philosophes ou même les penseurs en général, parce que c'est lié aux arts, aux sciences, ont à un moment donné tenté de comprendre le monde qui était le leur et comment ils ont fait.
Et puis comment ça a évolué dans l'histoire. Comment,
la pensée sur la politique entre Platon et Habermas aujourd'hui, pour prendre un philosophe actuel,
il reste des récurrences, il reste des vraies questions ouvertes qui le sont toujours depuis deux mille cinq cents ans, sinon ce ne serait pas de la philo.
La philo, c'est des questions qui seront toujours ouvertes. Sinon—
Qui amènent d'autres questions.
Une fois qu'elles se ferment, ça devient une science précise. La sociologie, la physique, la biologie, qui au départ étaient entièrement dans le champ de la philosophie, puis qui se sont autonomisées parce qu'elles ont trouvé des réponses.
La chimie, le matérialisme, à la base, c'était des questions de philo et puis aujourd'hui—
Oui, les atomistes grecs et tout ça, bien sûr. Et puis dès qu'on a trouvé des réponses, ben c'est sorti du champ de la philo.
C'est devenu une science autonome. Et donc ce qui reste en philo, c'est des questions qui restent ouvertes. Donc elles sont ouvertes, mais évidemment, les réponses évoluent dans le temps.
Et c'est ça, moi, qui me passionne.
Est-ce que tu as en mémoire une lecture en particulier ou qui a changé ta vie ou un truc où vraiment, tu n'en dormais plus la nuit ? Ça t'a secoué l'esprit.
Je sais pas si quelque chose m'a déjà empêché de dormir quand même, mais il y a beaucoup de lectures, en fait, qui ont changé un peu ma vie.
Un peu quoi, qui m'ont fait évoluer, vraiment beaucoup. Je dirais que le philosophe qui me fascine toujours le plus aujourd'hui, c'est Emmanuel Kant.
Donc un philosophe allemand, Critique de la raison pure, Critique de la faculté du jugement, etc. Qu'il écrit à la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle, 1780, sortent ses grandes œuvres.
Je le trouve fascinant. Le personnage est fascinant. Il écrit ses premières grandes œuvres à 60 ans, donc il a maturé ça pendant 40 ans de sa vie avant de sortir Critique de la raison pure.
Un projet démiurgique quoi. Et de se dire : Bon, je vais refonder la connaissance humaine. Rien que ça.
C'est ambitieux.
C'est très ambitieux. Je suis pas d'accord avec beaucoup de choses qu'il dit.
Mais tu respectes l'ambition.
Mais je respecte l'ambition. Et Kant, mais comme d'autres grands philosophes, au fond, c'est la même expérience que vous allez dans une cathédrale.
C'est-à-dire que c'est une architecture incroyable—
Mh.
Phénoménale, mais personne peut habiter dedans. C'est-à-dire, on se dit, c'est trop grand quoi. Et puis ça a mal vieilli quoi.
Si vous allez voir une cathédrale, c'est parfois un peu désuet, mais en même temps, la cathédrale, tout le monde la voit dans une ville.
C'est un repère quoi. C'est quelque chose qui joue un rôle. Et Kant, c'est ça. Mais comme d'autres hein, vous pourrez en citer cinquante autres, mais qui ont construit des cathédrales.
Et quand vous allez voir cette cathédrale, même si vous êtes nul en architecture, vous trouvez ça beau, vous êtes impressionné, vous êtes ému en fait par cette construction humaine incroyable qui est une cathédrale.
J'ai été voir Gaudí à Barcelone récemment, c'est émouvant, c'est de beauté quoi. Et Kant, c'est ça aussi quoi. Il lance une construction incroyable, construction humaine aussi, mais qui n'est pas matérielle, mais c'est pas grave.
Et puis moi, voilà, je suis ému par ce type de construction. Je suis touché par ça, même si, à bien des égards, pour beaucoup de conclusions kantiennes, je ne suis pas d'accord.
Puis je continue mon parcours, mais—
Mais on sort en tout cas admiratif—
Ah oui.
Dans la contemplation—
Oui, oui.
Le respect du travail.
J'aime toujours, moi, me mettre dans une bibliothèque, prendre un livre. Ça peut être un Kant, ça peut être des philosophes qui sont— Un Spinoza, qui sera pas du tout d'accord avec Kant.
C'est l'opposé, quasiment. Et lire au calme d'une bibliothèque un Spinoza ou un Kant ou un Grand, ben c'est la même expérience pour moi qu'aller dans une cathédrale ou aller face à une autre œuvre immense en fait.
C'est une œuvre, c'est une œuvre d'art, mais qui est philosophique, de réflexion. Mais au fond, pour moi, c'est le même type d'émotion.
Et c'est comme aller dans un grand musée voir un grand tableau. Et j'aime ça. J'aime ce côté un peu contemplatif de la philosophie, de voir l'écriture
et surtout, alors quand on va dans l'histoire loin, même des philosophes grecs, des Aristote, etc.
C'est quand même très impressionnant de voir que les questions qu'ils ouvrent sont toujours posées aujourd'hui. Les termes qu'ils ont utilisés sont toujours utilisés.
Leur réflexion sur la démocratie, par exemple, des Grecs, reste aujourd'hui valable. En tout cas, discutée, conversée aujourd'hui.
C'est toujours l'objet de dialogues et de discussions.
Mais en tout cas, ce que tu mets en avant, au-delà de ce que ça aurait permis éventuellement en termes de sculpter tes convictions,
donner forme à une pensée chez toi, tu mets surtout en avant le goût de, voilà, l'histoire de la philosophie,
l'évolution à travers les époques et les clashes entre différents courants.
Est-ce que c'est ça qui, du coup, a fait que, à l'issue de ton année d'études en journalisme, fait que tu t'es très naturellement dirigé vers le journalisme politique en particulier ?
Ben en fait, je crois pas tellement.
OK.
J'ai au début—
Ah, c'était au pif de nouveau.
Ben, c'est-à-dire, je crois pas que c'est ça qui m'a conduit au journalisme. Ça m'a conduit aux études de philo.
OK.
Non, le journalisme, je l'ai choisi euh—
Ouais, je veux dire précisément ton goût pour les idées.
Ah oui oui, ça oui. T'as raison. Effectivement, j'adore les idées. J'adore le débat d'idées, même si j'en mesure toutes les limites aussi, parce que les débats d'idées cachent souvent des intérêts aussi, hein.
J'veux dire, quand on vote ou même—
On est biaisé, ouais.
On sait bien que la situation, par exemple, financière de quelqu'un influence beaucoup la manière dont il vote. Donc les idées là-dedans, elles servent souvent de justification a posteriori d'une position.
Il suffit de voir dans le débat géostratégique ou géopolitique entre la Russie, les États-Unis, etc. Les idées servent souvent plutôt à justifier des actions, une guerre, des impôts, peu importe.
A posteriori, donc il faut pas surestimer. Je suis pas un idéaliste en histoire. Je pense pas que les idées déterminent l'histoire.
Elles jouent un rôle, certainement, mais sans complètement les déterminer. Je ne tranche pas entre Marx et Kant là-dessus, parce que voilà, un matérialiste, un idéaliste.
Mais, en tout cas, je ne donne pas trop d'importance à l'idée, mais mon rapport à la politique, c'était quand même à la base ça, quoi.
C'est-à-dire justement ce terrain qui est à la croisée des convictions, des idées et puis des intérêts, des rapports de force, des responsabilités.
C'est quelque part l'idée qui rentre dans le tas de fumier, quoi.
C'est— À un moment donné, il faut mettre les mains dans le cambouis, dans la saleté, dans— il faut faire des compromis, il faut parfois faire des coups bas, qui sont liés à l'exercice du pouvoir.
Il n'y a pas de fatalité. On pourrait certainement diriger mieux, mais en tout cas, il faut à un moment donné mettre ces idées à l'épreuve de choses qui sont beaucoup plus terre à terre.
Moi, j'aime bien cette rencontre-là. On peut pas faire de politique sans conviction et sans idées. C'est pas possible. Sinon, c'est de la gestion.
Autant mettre des hommes d'affaires et des chefs d'entreprise à la direction du pays, quoi voilà, c'est tout. C'est pas que de la gestion, la politique.
Forcément, il y a des idées, mais on ne peut pas faire de politique non plus sans gestion, sans rapport de force, sans des choses beaucoup plus matérielles.
C'est la rencontre des deux qui fait la beauté et la difficulté de la politique.
Alors, on sent que c'est toujours là chez toi aujourd'hui. C'est quoi la différence entre le Bertrand de 2003 et le Bertrand de 2023-2024 ?
C'est bête à dire, mais c'est pas parce que c'est évident que c'est faux. C'est l'expérience quoi. C'est sûr qu'après vingt ans, je garde—
Aucun rêve brisé, aucune ambition écrasée, aucune frustration, aucune désillusion ?
Pas une désillusion, en tout cas sur le métier et sur le journalisme en tant que tel. Non, non, je garde le feu sacré.
Après, c'est sûr que l'évolution du politique ou l'évolution du monde, je me pose comme beaucoup de gens une série de questions quoi.
Et par rapport à il y a vingt ans, il y a des choses qui me paraissent avoir été dans le mauvais sens, d'autres qui ont plutôt été dans le bon sens.
Mais je suis pas un décliniste quoi. Je ne regarde pas les choses avec un regard : Non, c'était mieux avant. Mais effectivement, en vingt ans, j'allais dire quarante ans, ce sera dans vingt ans.
Non, mais en une vingtaine d'années—
On prend de l'avance.
C'est sûr qu'il y a des choses que j'ai faites ou que j'ai écrites il y a une vingtaine d'années que je n'écrirais peut-être plus aujourd'hui.
Et encore heureux d'ailleurs, parce que ce serait dommage de pas avoir évolué.
Forcément, l'absence de changement, ce serait un peu triste.
Oui, oui, oui.
Le journalisme, ça reste un secteur assez précaire.
C'est incroyable le nombre d'anciens journalistes que je croise et qui sont devenus porte-parole pour les partis politiques ou communicants pour une boîte ou copywriter pour une banque, etc.
Chez toi, ça a plutôt bien marché. T'es rapidement arrivé à la matinale de la Première et tu y es toujours et tu es tout à fait respecté dans le paysage journalistique.
Comment est-ce que tu expliques ça ? En toute humilité.
Je pense qu'il y a quand même, de la part de la RTBF, c'est sans doute vrai dans d'autres médias, mais je les connais pas très bien.
J'ai jamais travaillé au Soir. J'ai pas beaucoup d'expérience ailleurs, donc je vais pas faire du comparatif.
Je peux juste observer qu'à la RTBF, il y a une volonté quand même de sécuriser le personnel dans les fonctions, en tout cas
peut-être certaines catégories de personnel, mais je dois pas parler pour tout le monde, mais en tout cas, il y a des opportunités de durée quand on apporte
ce qui est jugé nécessaire, voilà, dans la fonction, parce que la RTBF est pas un employeur qui a tendance à mettre
excessivement de pression sur ses employés et leur laisse une certaine liberté, une certaine, dans le choix de la carrière.
Si vous voulez faire du documentaire et puis du terrain, de l'international, etc., vous pourrez avoir une carrière très variée.
Moi, c'est vrai que j'ai toujours préféré taper sur le même clou. Je trouve qu'il y a un aboutissement à ça quand ça fait quelques années qu'on est dans le même type de fonction.
Je dis pas que c'est bien ou mal, hein, je dis c'est ma manière de fonctionner. Moi, je trouve qu'on trouve un certain épanouissement de pouvoir durer, de pouvoir marquer un peu les choses quoi.
J'ai fait dix ans d'interview. Ben si j'avais fait un an ou deux, même pour moi ou pour les auditeurs, j'aurais peut-être été un peu fugace quoi.
Je trouve que quand on en fait pendant une dizaine d'années, on marque un peu son temps. C'est pas très humble ce que je dis, mais voilà, on marque un peu de sa présence l'antenne.
Et puis on est aussi marqué par son expérience, donc on sait la rendre utile pour les auditrices et les auditeurs quoi, parce que— Donc moi, j'aime bien l'idée de durée dans quelque chose.
C'est vrai qu'on m'a déjà proposé pas mal de fois des choses. Pourquoi tu changerais pas ? Pourquoi tu changerais pas ? Je trouve que c'est un biais comme facteur de la réussite de pouvoir brûler les navires derrière soi, de changer,
de monter.
Pour moi pas. Je pense que le, un facteur de réussite, c'est de pouvoir rester pendant des années à faire quelque chose si on le fait bien.
La reconnaissance des pairs, la reconnaissance du public.
Oui, de s'améliorer.
Ouais.
Et puis de taper sur un même clou. Je pense qu'il y a une sorte de fidélité aussi. Pour moi, c'est important, une fidélité à la RTBF, une fidélité aussi aux auditrices et aux auditeurs, de pas changer comme ça tout le temps.
C'est intéressant parce que tu réponds comme si c'était finalement ton choix. Tu dis : Ah ben, j'ai choisi la durée, ça me plaît plutôt que l'ascension, plutôt que de partir ailleurs.
Alors que ma question partait plutôt sur l'angle de tous ces pigistes qui travaillent à la pige et qui ne s'en sortent pas et qui finissent par quitter le métier parce que—
Sur la précarité, tu disais.
Voilà, c'est ça. Beaucoup d'appelés, très peu d'élus, finalement. Toi, tu es un élu.
Les conditions se sont dégradées. C'est-à-dire qu'au moment où je suis arrivé, c'était le début de la fin du statut à la RTBF.
J'ai pas de statut, moi, je suis un contractuel, c'est-à-dire—
En CDD ou quoi ?
Non, je suis en CDI, mais j'ai un contrat de type privé, c'est-à-dire j'ai pas de statut de type fonctionnaire, c'est-à-dire—
D'accord. Ah oui, c'est ça. Oui, d'accord.
Ce qui existe de plus en plus dans la fonction publique. Donc moi, j'ai un contrat qui peut être, dont on peut mettre fin comme un contractuel normal dans une entreprise privée.
C'est la même chose. À la différence de beaucoup de mes collègues plus anciens. Donc tous ceux de ma génération qui sont arrivés au début des années 2000, c'était fini.
Ça a été fini dans fin des années 90, le statut. Donc ça, il y a une précarisation un peu qui a commencé à ce moment-là.
D'ailleurs, on a eu des mouvements sociaux de jeunes journalistes de la RTBF pour se battre un peu pour justement ne pas avoir trop de CDD au début de notre carrière.
Mais ça n'a fait que se dégrader.
Avec Internet, notamment, oui.
À partir du moment où on peut s'informer très facilement en lisant deux, trois titres, trois titres d'articles.
Non, non, mais ce que je veux dire, oui, non, c'est pas ça. Ce que je veux dire, c'est que les jeunes qui sont arrivés après moi ont toujours eu des conditions plus difficiles pour rentrer à la RTBF.
Ah oui.
Voilà, il fallait de plus en plus de contrats. Ils étaient parfois des années avec des CDD, parfois d'un jour ou d'une demi-journée.
Ils avaient des fardes, j'ai vu des collègues, des fardes de contrats ici à la RTBF, ce qui n'aurait été impensable dans les années 90 et au début des années 2000, encore quand je suis arrivé.
Donc, je dis pas que je suis un élu. J'ai eu un peu de chance aussi d'arriver à un moment où il y avait des conditions sociales un peu meilleures.
Alors la RTBF, suite à des mouvements sociaux, à l'action de la société des journalistes, et cetera, a quand même revu un peu les choses.
Désormais, il y a quand même un peu, je trouve, plus de justice qui est revenue, mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu des périodes où ça a été trop loin dans la précarité.
Donc cela dit, par rapport à la presse écrite, je crois que même les conditions dégradées pour les jeunes de la RTBF qui ont suivi un peu mon époque, étaient encore pires ailleurs. Dans le—
Et quoi ? C'est de par le statut service public de la RTBF ou plutôt le côté audiovisuel ou ?
Oui, non, je parle pas de ce côté audiovisuel, parce qu'à RTL, les conditions sont très très dures pour les jeunes journalistes, encore plus qu'ici.
Non, oui, c'était sans doute quand même un reliquat du fait qu'à la RTBF, on a gardé des syndicats puissants,
qu'on a gardé une société de journalistes qui était en débat avec la direction sur les conditions des jeunes, même si on n'a pas pu éviter une dégradation.
Ça, je crois que dans le monde du travail en général, la RTBF a suivi, mais en s'adaptant un petit peu, voilà, en étant peut-être moins violente que ce qu'on a pu connaître comme dégradation dans le milieu du travail.
Mais c'est vrai que le monde du journalisme en particulier, les conditions sociales du journalisme se sont dégradées.
C'est effarant dans tous les médias et la RTBF n'y a pas échappé, même si elle y a été un peu moins confrontée que d'autres de par les conditions internes et le dialogue social, quoi.
Donc tu réponds très humblement en disant : « Je suis tombé au bon moment ».
Oui, je pense pour ça, oui.
Oui, oui. Je suis pas tout à fait dans le syndrome de l'imposteur non plus. Faut pas dire que je suis là par hasard, même si parfois, je suis quand même— je me dis : ça aurait pu se passer tout à fait autrement.
Je me souviens bien quand je suis arrivé ici pour un stage à la RTBF, après trois semaines, Simone Drummond, qui était rédactrice en chef à l'époque de la radio, m'a dit : « Est-ce que ça t'intéresse un contrat de neuf mois ?
» Je savais pas dire non, évidemment, quand on sort de l'école. Et en fait, ce contrat de neuf mois, ça s'appelait à la RTBF un contrat pont.
C'est parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de pensionnés qui avaient fait un plan de départ, de pré-pensionnés.
Et donc tout d'un coup, ils se sont retrouvés avec des postes à pourvoir. Et justement, j'étais stagiaire à ce moment-là.
Je serais arrivé six mois après dans un même stage, j'aurais sans doute pas eu ce contrat ou pas comme ça. Donc oui, il faut quand même de la chance.
Y a rien à faire. Il faut arriver dans un moment où il y a des emplois disponibles. C'est de la chance et en même temps, voilà, j'avais des capacités sans doute, mais il faut les deux.
Je ne mets pas ma réussite uniquement sur le compte de mes talents. Ce serait vraiment immodeste quoi.
C'est, oui, c'est la rencontre des deux. Donc, je le disais, rétrospective, pas seulement sur toi, mais aussi sur le journalisme politique de manière générale.
Alors, les sondages qu'on peut lire régulièrement chaque année montrent à chaque fois des trucs absolument consternants sur l'appréciation du public pour les figures politiques, pour les médias, pour les journalistes.
Et c'est de plus en plus bas. C'est taux d'appréciation, taux de confiance. C'est, voilà, il y a des différences entre la Flandre et le sud du pays, mais ça reste quand même assez effrayant.
Voir parfois des violences contre les journalistes. Je pense notamment à ton collègue Eric Boever lors de, c'est pendant le Covid, il me semble, qu'il s'est fait agresser.
Est-ce que c'est une différence, voilà, par rapport à il y a vingt ans, que tu observes au jour le jour ? Est-ce que tu as eu des expériences négatives ? Est-ce que...
Oui, oui, il y a un rapport au journaliste comme, je mets vraiment des guillemets, mais je pense que les sociologues, certains sociologues sont d'accord avec moi, comme figure d'autorité, hein.
Comme on peut mettre à côté d'autres figures d'autorité, le professeur, le médecin, le prêtre, enfin que sais-je, dans la société, de figures d'autorité possibles, qui sont contestées.
On vit à maints égards une forme de crise de l'autorité ou une remise en question de toute une série de figures d'autorité pour des bonnes raisons de critique
de leur position sociale, parfois aussi pour des mauvaises, à mon avis, on pourrait y revenir, mais...
Donc oui, il y a une montée de,
même de la violence, mais ça, pour l'avoir déjà discuté avec des médecins,
ils subissent aussi de plus en plus de violence par rapport à des certificats qu'ils remplissent pas, un traitement qu'ils veulent pas donner.
Bon, les relations sont plus tendues. Moi, je n'associe pas ça qu'aux journalistes. Je pense qu'il faut vraiment le replacer dans une,
une évolution sociologique plus générale de la société, parce que sinon, on a tendance à avoir une vision un peu corporatiste de ce qui nous arrive, alors que ça nous arrive pas qu'à nous.
Ça, c'est vraiment important. Par contre, pour en rester sur notre fonction, oui, il y a une montée en tension. Et moi, je l'ai pas visualisée physiquement.
Enfin, j'ai jamais été victime. Peut-être que ma carrure fait un peu peur. Mais non, alors, je l'ai déjà vécu sur les réseaux sociaux, cette violence-là, oui, bien sûr.
Ça, je m'en doutais.
Bien sûr, fort.
On y reviendra d'ailleurs. J'ai quelques exemples en tête, intéressants. Toujours dans cette idée de rétrospective, j'ai ici listé cinq événements majeurs, on va dire.
En tout cas, ceux que j'ai retenus de ces vingt dernières années. On va un petit peu revenir dessus sans forcément, voilà, c'est pas le but de,
de réexpliquer la crise des cinq cent quarante et un jours aujourd'hui, mais plutôt parler un petit peu des coulisses, l'envers des décors, comment ça a été vécu à l'intérieur de la rédaction de la RTBF.
Donc le premier que j'ai noté ici, c'est la crise deux mille sept, deux mille onze. Rappel, voilà, victoire électorale du cartel
CD&V et N-VA, qui pesait très très lourd à ce moment-là et qui soutenait une large réforme de l'État et la scission immédiate de BHV.
Et voilà, ça avait duré à l'époque cent nonante-quatre jours de négociations. À l'époque, c'était un record.
Le record précédent, c'était cent quarante-neuf jours. Aujourd'hui, six mois et demi, c'est un petit peu du pipi de chat, hein, je trouve, pour la formation d'un gouvernement en Belgique.
Quel souvenir est-ce que tu gardes de cette époque et du traitement qui avait été fait, journalistique ?
Oh, j'en garde un souvenir, je pense, d'inconscience. C'est-à-dire, je pense qu'on était inconscient de ce qui aujourd'hui apparaît évident, c'est que c'est à ce moment-là que la Belgique est vraiment rentrée dans l'anormalité politique.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a eu des gouvernements—
Anormalité.
Anormalité politique. C'est devenu— jusque-là, on avait eu donc les gouvernements des années nonante, les gouvernements—
Beaucoup de PS.
De Haene, PSC, PS. Et puis là, c'était le gouvernement Verhofstadt, deux gouvernements de suite. Monsieur, voilà. Et puis c'est devenu un terme avec Leterme.
On n'a pas réussi en deux mille sept, deux mille neuf, deux mille onze. Des élections régionales et puis des élections fédérales, des discussions à rallonge et des difficultés de commencer à former des gouvernements qui sont devenus chroniques.
Voilà, c'est à ce moment-là qu'on est—
L'inconscience.
Oui, ben on n'avait pas conscience qu'on rentrait là-dedans. C'est peut-être un petit moment difficile, mais ce qu'on n'avait pas conscience, on ne pouvait pas, je crois, c'est que c'était structurel.
Là, on voit que c'est structurel. Ça fait vingt ans qu'on n'est pas sorti de ces problèmes. Donc ce type d'inconscience.
Et puis alors, bon parce que moi, j'étais jeune journaliste aussi, donc je ne me flagelle pas en disant ça. Simplement, c'était pas évident à percevoir.
Et alors aussi, avec le recul, mais ça, c'est pas tellement un souvenir, c'est plutôt une leçon que je tire aujourd'hui, c'est le manque— on avait le nez dans le guidon, voilà, comme journaliste, tant francophone que flamand.
Et j'en ai déjà discuté avec des journalistes flamands. On était un petit peu comme défendeur de notre communauté dans ces difficultés.
J'allais en parler.
Les Flamands défendaient les thèses flamandes sur la scission de BHV. Ils ne comprenaient pas pourquoi on voulait pas scinder.
Et les francophones défendaient les thèses francophones : on n'est demandeur de rien. Et pourquoi est-ce qu'on scinderait quoi ?
Le personnage central dans cet événement-là, c'était, voilà, sans doute Yves Leterme.
Oui. Je dirais que c'était De Wever, le personnage central.
Ah oui, intéressant. Oui, peut-être un peu plus dans l'ombre, mais, mais—
C'est lui. C'est lui, il a fondé son parti en deux mille cinq. C'est lui, le personnage qui naît là.
Oui.
Leterme, c'est une erreur de l'histoire.
Je, la raison pour laquelle je dis ça, c'est vraiment médiatiquement—
Oui.
Il y avait vraiment un focus sur notamment le fait qu'il a chanté la Marseillaise.
Ce genre de trucs-là.
Oui.
Je me souviens de... C'était à Val Duchesse, c'est ça hein, que ça se passait ?
Oui, les négociations, oui.
Il y avait ces caméras de la RTBF qui le filmaient en train de fumer une cigarette à l'extérieur et lui pointer du doigt les caméras.
Il fait : « Eh, qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? »
Oui.
Il y avait des tensions. Ouais, il a fait des commentaires ensuite sur la RTBF en faisant des comparaisons avec, je ne sais plus quelle radio du Rwanda ou enfin, des trucs comme ça.
Oui, il nous a traités de Radio Mille Collines, bien sûr.
Voilà, voilà.
Oui, oui.
Donc, tu parlais de nez dans le guidon. On défend très fort le point de vue francophone—
Chacun.
Et cetera. Oui, des deux côtés, oui. Qu'est-ce que tu aurais fait différemment, en fait ?
Ah, je pense qu'avec le recul, c'est facile hein, ça, c'est vraiment de l'uchronie que je fais. Voilà. Si avec l'expérience que j'avais aujourd'hui, je revenais à cette époque-là, je serais dans une posture beaucoup plus critique
des partis francophones et flamands, mais on l'était déjà, nous, côté francophone, des partis flamands, en se disant : « Mais pourquoi ils viennent avec cette histoire de BHV ?
Il faudrait le scinder tout de suite. Et nos droits et les droits des francophones de la périphérie. Et s'il faut, on, tant pis, on votera pas, quitte à ce que la Belgique se déchire quasiment en deux.
On est prêt à aller jusqu'au bout. » Donc ça, on était déjà critique des pa— mais on était très peu critique des partis francophones ou trop peu, parce que c'était quand même un manque de vision.
Aujourd'hui, BHV est scindé et tout le monde s'en fout.
Oui.
Donc-
C'est, le jour où ça a été annoncé, c'était la : Ah bon ?
Voilà. Parce qu'il y a une solution en même temps. Voilà, on a trouvé une solution qui avait déjà d'ailleurs été plus ou moins mise en place dès le pacte d'Egmont en mille neuf cent septante-huit, d'ailleurs.
C'était l'idée que les francophones de périphérie pourraient, s'ils s'inscrivent, voter pour des listes à Bruxelles.
Enfin, ce qui existe déjà aujourd'hui, mais que l'arrondissement serait scindé. Bon aujourd'hui, qu'on reparle de ça d'ailleurs, c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'est battu sur ces ba-- ?
C'est, ça devient presque impossible à expliquer.
C'est symbolique.
Oui, il y avait un symbole. Et puis, parce que le problème, si vous voulez, c'est que la manière dont les partis flamands
sont arrivés dans cette affaire en disant : « On scinde, il faut cinq minutes de courage politique », la fameuse phrase de Leterme.
Et puis il y a rien d'autre, il y a pas de négo, on a juste-- était très mauvaise. Enfin, ça a cabré les francophones.
Mal, mal reçu, oui.
Mais les francophones auraient dû se dire : « Ben oui, scindons BHV, demandons peut-être quelque chose en échange, mais pas ce qu'on a demandé nécessairement au début, où on voulait quasiment élargir Bruxelles à six communes, et cetera.
» C'était, c'est énorme quoi, comme revendication. Et c'était surtout une insulte à l'histoire, je pense, autour de la manière dont on avait fait le fédéralisme dans ce pays.
Oui.
Mais, mais donc-
Il y a aussi un côté très attachement, la terre, la nation, l'identité flamande.
Oui.
Ou vraiment l'idée de : on élargit Bruxelles. C'est inaudible.
Oui oui, c'était inaudible. Et je pense que les francophones le savaient. C'était d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils l'ont proposé.
Pour être sûr qu'il y ait pas de solution.
Et donc c'est une erreur. Stratégiquement, c'est une erreur, parce que ça a donné du grain à moudre au récit des nationalistes flamands qui, je rappelle, en deux mille cinq, De Wever
n'atteint pas le seuil électoral avec son parti, avec la N-VA.
C'est fou de le dire aujourd'hui, mais il est né de cette frustration que les francophones n'en avaient rien à faire.
On pouvait arriver avec des arrêts du Conseil d'État, de la Cour constitutionnelle, plutôt ici, sur un point, la cession de BHV, et on se faisait rejeter comme ça.
Ça a été pris comme une immense ingratitude en fait, ou une immense incompréhension.
Or, je ne dis pas qu'il n'y avait pas des arguments côté francophone, mais on aurait dû comprendre que ça allait générer ce genre de choses et que donc on aurait tout intérêt à dire : « Ben oui, scindons BHV.
Voilà quelques éléments qu'on met sur la table pour nous, francophones, et on scinde BHV, on fait une négociation ». Parce que la manière dont on s'est comporté à ce moment-là, à mon avis, a nourri.
Alors, aurait-on pu l'empêcher, le nationalisme flamand ?
Tu parles des médias ?
Non, non. Oui, oui, mais, et les politiques aussi. Mais, et les médias, non, c'est les politiques en premier, mais les médias, et c'est pour ça qu'on a été traités de Radio Mille Collines, c'était excessif.
Et en même temps, c'est vrai que la manière dont la RTBF, mais les autres médias couvraient à l'époque la crise, mais les médias flamands, c'était la même chose de leur côté hein.
Je-- vraiment, on était tous un peu aveugles, avaient tendance à soutenir les thèses de chaque communauté quoi. Et donc à, pas criminaliser, mais à, en tout cas diminuer ou à parfois caricaturer un peu les thèses en face.
Ça, oui, je peux reconnaître que c'est ce qui s'est passé.
Et donc avec le recul, aujourd'hui, je crois que ça aussi, cette affaire de BHV a éloigné plein de gens de la politique quoi, parce que c'était incompréhensible,
particu-- alors peut-être pas pour les francophones de périphérie, voilà, pour les six communes là, tout ça, ces gens-là, évidemment, je comprends qu'ils s'y intéressent. Pour le reste-
Il y a un instant, on essaie de s'en souvenir, on a un peu du mal à expliquer parce que...
Oui, oui, parce que c'est... Mais c'est quasiment une constante des crises en Belgique. Regardez, dans les années septante, fin des années septante, il y a plusieurs gouvernements qui chutent, les gouvernements Tindemans,
il y a le pacte d'Egmont.
La part que prend les ennuis linguistiques et communautaires est énorme quoi, dans les médias et dans la société. Et le média est un miroir réfléchissant, déformant.
Mais voilà. Et en même temps, on est dans les années septante, c'est la crise du pétrole, c'est un changement stratégique majeur qui arrive pour le monde, les finances publiques explosent.
On a plein de problèmes quoi. Et on passe du temps politique et médiatique sur des débats, en fait, qui sont pas concernants, enfin, qui ne touchent pas à la vie quotidienne des gens.
C'est ça le... Et ça suscite un rejet, je crois, une coupure aussi entre le politique et les citoyens, entre les citoyens et les médias.
Et donc, à refaire, je laisserai les politiques faire leur bazar et je dirais : « Faisons moins sur cette affaire. Faisons plus de sujets qui s'intéressent au pouvoir d'achat, qui s'intéressent à plein de choses.
» Enfin voilà, à la santé, mais moins à ces sujets-là, parce que c'est trop quoi.
C'est une critique qui est pertinente en Belgique, mais en fait, assez pertinente même à l'Occident en général en fait hein.
Aux États-Unis aussi, on peut faire ce genre de critiques, en France aussi. Le décalage entre la politique politicienne et le problème des vrais gens.
Oui, effectivement. Et ça, je crois que c'est quand même en train de changer positivement aujourd'hui. Alors, peut-être ça va même trop dans l'autre sens, mais effectivement, je pense qu'on dépense moins d'énergie.
Moi, je le vois ici à la RTBF, à suivre toute une série de petites querelles internes, etc. On les suit moins qu'avant.
Avec la Vivaldi, c'est compliqué quand même.
Avec la Vivaldi, c'est compliqué, c'est vrai, mais quand même, on les suit moins qu'avant, on met plus d'énergie. Et ça, il y a eu plusieurs signaux qui nous ont quand même interpellés à la RTBF, des sondages qu'on faisait sur,
comme Noir, jaune, blues, etc.
Mais il y en a eu d'autres où on voyait des investissements d'une partie de plus en plus grande des citoyens dans le politique, etc.
Et donc, on se dit : Il faut qu'on retourne auprès des gens, qu'on fasse, on réinvestisse dans le reportage, dans des enquêtes.
C'est pas se détourner de la politique, c'est se détourner d'une certaine manière de faire de la politique. Et effectivement, il faut qu'on en parle autrement.
Il faut qu'on parle des problèmes qui sont des problèmes politiques, mais pas nécessairement aller passer des heures et des heures à essayer de comprendre pourquoi un tel n'est pas sur la liste.
Est-ce qu'il a été trahi par tel autre, etc. C'est pas que c'est pas important, hein, c'est qu'il y a des choses plus importantes.
C'est sûr qu'une différence remarquable entre aujourd'hui et donc il y a seize, dix-sept ans, c'est qu'effectivement, on est plus en train de regretter les conflits au sein de la Vivaldi et les disputes et de se dire : « Mais qu'est-ce que...
Pourquoi est-ce que ce gouvernement ne peut pas avoir un peu plus de cohésion ? » Alors qu'effectivement, peut-être en 2007, il y a peut-être plus ce biais de...
Et l'intérêt des francophones là-dedans, dans tout ça. Et voilà, donc, c'est que là-dessus, je suis d'accord avec toi, ça a évolué.
Et je suis d'accord également sur le fait que, voilà, quand je dis aux gens que je rencontre : « Tiens, j'ai obtenu une interview avec Caroline Désir, avec Zakia Khattabi, avec Thomas Dermine.
» Les gens me disent : « Ah, c'est qui ? »
Oui.
C'est... Voilà.
Oui, oui. Il y a une désaffiliation quoi. On se... Et ça, il faut s'en rendre compte. Et moi, je ne crois pas...
Enfin c'est bon. Alors là, c'est vraiment, je dis le mot croyance parce que c'est aussi peut-être un idéal que j'ai, mais je ne crois pas que ça veut dire qu'on se désintéresse du politique.
Les idées, encore une fois, les débats, les discussions, quand on parle politique, en parlant des idées, des projets, etc.
Ça continue à intéresser beaucoup de gens. Par contre, c'est vrai que les questions de rue de la Loi sont moins attirantes.
C'est pas pour ça, je disais, j'en parle souvent, donc moi, dans mes chroniques, de ces questions-là, parce qu'elles jouent un rôle, mais j'ai tendance quand même à en mettre moins et à faire moins qu'au début.
Et je parle plus des idées, je parle plus de la manière dont on fait de la politique et pas des problèmes constamment.
Parce qu'en fait, les disputes au sein de la Vivaldi, ben oui, mais enfin, je veux dire, il y a toujours eu des disputes dans les gouvernements.
On en parlait peut-être un peu moins dans les années nonante, etc. Mais enfin, il y avait déjà des tensions. C'est pas ça qui me marque.
Ce qui me marque beaucoup, c'est le fait que on se désaffilie du politique, mais en même temps, on attend de plus en plus d'eux.
C'est ça qui est paradoxal. C'est qu'il y a un rejet du politique parce que c'est de plus en plus difficile pour lui de décider.
Il faut faire des coalitions à plus. Il y a l'Europe qui impose des règles, il y a le droit, le droit de l'homme, le juridique, etc.
Qui impose de plus en plus de contraintes.
La lasagne institutionnelle.
La lasagne. Si je prends une métaphore, dans les années 80 encore, la politique, c'était un gros navire, on tirait à gauche, le navire allait à gauche.
Maintenant, c'est toujours un gros navire, mais qui est dans un canal. Donc, on ne peut pas faire demi-tour hein. Les canaux, c'est les règles européennes, etc.
On peut aller un peu à gauche du canal, un peu à droite du canal, pas beaucoup plus. Et dans le cockpit, il y a des boutons dans tous les sens et il y a sept pilotes.
Et tout le monde se dispute.
Et tout le monde se dispute. Bon, c'est plus compliqué également, c'est indéniable. Et ces contraintes-là, il faut les intégrer, elles font partie et c'est vrai dans toutes les démocraties occidentales.
On est de plus en plus contraints, les dirigeants, par toute une série d'éléments, notamment juridiques, etc. En Europe,
c'est l'Union européenne en particulier qui est parfois considérée comme une perte de souveraineté pour les dirigeants qui ne peuvent plus faire aller le bateau complètement à gauche, complètement à droite.
On ne peut pas dévaluer le franc comme on l'a fait dans les années 80, par exemple. Donc, ils ont moins de pouvoir. Ça, c'est indéniable.
Et en même temps, on leur demande de plus en plus de choses où on est de plus en plus exigeant d'eux, notamment en matière de droit.
Vous voyez, ce paradoxe-là, il est, à mon avis, à la source du malaise quoi. C'est qu'ils peuvent faire moins qu'avant, ils sont moins capables de faire bouger des choses qu'avant et on leur en demande plus.
Effectivement, eux, en premier, moi qui les observe, je peux voir un peu le désarroi dans lequel ils sont par rapport à ça.
Vraiment, je pense qu'ils se rendent compte qu'ils sont mal aimés. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est évident, ils vont dans la rue, ils sont beaucoup, eux, en premier, plus que les journalistes, reçoivent des insultes, des mails atroces.
Enfin bon, bref. Et en même temps, ils sentent un vrai souci de demande de plus en plus précis pour toute une série de sujets quoi.
On attend du politique plus qu'avant. Donc c'est, voilà, ce paradoxe-là est ingérable, en fait. Je sais-
Et ça a commencé, donc les premiers indicateurs ont commencé déjà en 2007, je dirais, pendant cette crise-là ?
Bah, c'est,
à mon avis, c'est quelque chose qui remonte encore
plus loin que ça, mais en tout cas, c'est à ce moment-là qu'en Belgique, on a commencé à avoir les effets, notamment à cause du vote des électeurs qui ont distribué les cartes de telle manière que c'est devenu encore plus compliqué.
Et chaque élection, c'est encore plus compliqué et je ne sais pas comment ça va aller ici.
De telle manière que, ben, effectivement, ce qui reste d'un pouvoir déjà
enchaîné, comme disait Alain Eraly dans un de ses livres, qui date justement des années 2000, où il disait— c'est un chef de cabinet, en fait, qui avait écrit un bouquin,
puisqu'il est prof toujours à l'ULB, de sociologie, mais il a été chef de cabinet libéral pendant quelques années.
Et à la fin de son expérience de chef de cabinet, il a écrit un bouquin vraiment très très chouette qui s'appelle Le pouvoir enchaîné, où il voit déjà toutes les contraintes qu'on a à décider, à pouvoir prendre une décision, tout ce qui
se met sur le chemin.
Et des contraintes législatives, hein, c'est normal, on ne passe pas des lois aussi facilement, etc. Enfin, il met tout bout à bout et il en sort un peu désabusé de se dire : Oh là là, c'est très difficile de faire bouger les choses.
Bon, c'est devenu encore plus difficile et en particulier
à cause de l'électeur ou grâce à l'électeur. Je ne le juge pas, l'électeur, il a toujours raison, soi-disant, mais l'idée, c'est que, ben, on a donné de telles cartes que c'est devenu encore plus difficile aux politiques de décider quoi.
L'évolution naturelle de la conversation que l'on a maintenant, ce serait de parler de la montée des extrêmes, mais je vais revenir à 2007 et en particulier au,
donc, au personnage qui, du coup, n'est pas le personnage central, euh, central, mais donc, Yves Leterme.
Les relations entre la RTBF et Yves Leterme, je l'évoquais il y a quelques instants. Comment est-ce que ça se passait dans les coulisses, les contacts entre, voilà, Yves Leterme et toi, par exemple ?
Moi, ça s'est toujours bien passé. On a toujours gardé contact. Je l'ai appelé, par exemple,
je m'en souviens très bien, après sa phrase, sa première phrase où il avait dérapé, où il avait dit : Les francophones ne sont pas en état intellectuel d'apprendre le néerlandais.
Ah, j'avais oublié ça.
Je me souviens bien de sa phrase-là. Le lendemain, je l'appelle, je lui dis : Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On va faire une interview parce que quand même, vous savez, ça choque.
Ben oui, c'est pas ce que j'ai voulu dire. Et j'ai voulu dire que, en fait, ils voulaient pas apprendre le néerlandais.
J'ai dit : Oui, enfin, vous avez dit qu'ils étaient pas en intellectuels. Enfin, je lui dis : Vous comprenez qu'on a l'impression que vous dites qu'on est bêtes quoi.
Voilà. Parce que c'est différent de dire qu'il y a pas vraiment de volonté-
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
D'apprendre la langue. Effectivement, beaucoup de francophones ne veulent pas tellement apprendre le néerlandais. Ils sont plus intéressés par l'anglais, etc.
Ont-ils tort d'ailleurs ? Maintenant, voilà, si on est dans le sud du pays, on peut se dire-
On va faire un podcast avec Philippe Van Parijs sur la question.
Voilà, voilà, voilà. Bon, je suis pas sûr de partager toutes ses thèses, mais c'est un débat en tout cas. Mais lui avait dit cette phrase-là.
Mais j'ai toujours gardé un bon contact et je pense que c'était un vrai maladroit. Un maladroit dans les expressions qu'il utilisait parce qu'il laissait sa pensée un peu s'exprimer comme ça.
Ce qui lui a coûté cher, par exemple, à Val Duchesse, où effectivement, avec des journalistes, parfois, il nous pointait du doigt, mais parfois aussi, même dans sa manière de négocier certains textes, il a commis des erreurs.
C'était un vrai maladroit. Il était pas adroit en politique. Voilà.
On parlera d'autres maladroits en politique dans un instant. Je vais quand même avancer un petit peu dans les-
Oui. Sinon, ça va prendre trop de temps.
Voilà, une série d'événements en tête. Les attentats de Bruxelles.
Mh.
Voilà, dans un autre genre. Comment est-ce que ça... Voilà, beaucoup d'émotion, forcément, au sein de la rédaction.
Quel souvenir est-ce que tu gardes de cet épisode-là ?
J'ai envie de dire, évidemment, il y a toute la tristesse de tout ça. C'est infiniment triste quoi.
Il y a pas d'autres mots. C'est évident. En même temps, moi, je reste marqué par des éléments plus positifs aussi.
Je me souviens que la réaction, moi, j'ai quand même été ému aussi par la réaction de plein de gens, qui se sont rassemblés, spontanément.
Je me souviens que le procureur général Frédéric Van Leeuw, au moment où l'État était extrêmement critiqué pour ne pas avoir su prendre les mesures.
Puis, il y avait aussi le, un terroriste en liberté qu'on traquait partout dans Bruxelles et qu'on trouvait pas.
Et on était considéré comme un État failli. Molenbeek était considéré comme le centre du djihadisme européen par défaut des autorités belges, etc.
Toute une série de critiques, bon, sur lesquelles on peut revenir, mais en partie fondées, malheureusement. Et lui a dit : « Bon, c'est vrai que notre État n'est pas nécessairement fort, notre nation
pas nécessairement non plus, puisque entre Flamands et Wallons, mais la société est forte.
» Et je trouvais que c'était pas faux. C'est-à-dire que moi, c'est ce que je retiens. Je trouve que la manière dont on a réussi, y compris dans une ville comme Bruxelles, où vivent des communautés très différentes, etc.
À faire part de la souffrance, faire part de notre tristesse, etc. Était très digne. Moi, c'est un élément que je retiens.
Finalement, je pourrais retenir plein d'éléments négatifs, mais moi, j'ai décidé de retenir plutôt ça, parce qu'il y a des pays où ça s'est pas toujours passé comme ça.
Oui, je trouve qu'on a plutôt été, j'ai plutôt été optimiste quand j'ai vu les premières réactions après, moi, en me disant : « Tiens, c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même quelque chose.
» On dit toujours, et c'est pas faux non plus, qu'on est de plus en plus individualistes, repliés sur nous-mêmes, qu'on ne sait plus penser autre et collectif.
Ce n'est pas faux, mais ce jour-là, j'ai l'impression qu'on a quand même été dans un moment de rassemblement collectif, ce qui est assez rare, finalement, dans notre pays.
On n'est pas entre Flamands et Wallons, mais c'est pas que ça. Entre toutes les communautés, rassemblées. Je trouve que ce rassemblement était vrai.
Il y a eu beaucoup de choses fausses dans les déclarations politiques et tout ça, mais ça, ça me paraissait vrai.
Je vais dans le désordre, hein, mais les fameux cinq cent quarante et un jours sans gouvernement, avec, donc, la montée écrasante de la N-VA au nord, du Parti socialiste au sud.
Quel, voilà-- encore une fois, sans forcément passer une heure à rappeler les faits, quel souvenir est-ce que tu gardes ?
Bon souvenir, mauvais souvenir ? Qu'est-ce qui t'a marqué ?
Non, juste un mauvais souvenir comme,
sans doute beaucoup d'autres, hein. Là, j'ai vraiment senti,
parce que finalement, on travaillait au début de la crise des cinq cent quarante et un jours, comme on faisait sur les autres formations de gouvernement, on racontait ce qui se passait.
Racontait : tel dossier a bloqué, tel dossier est passé. Oh tiens, ils ont quitté la table et puis ils se remettent ensemble.
Enfin bon, on racontait le jour le jour. Et pendant cinq cent quarante et un jours, évidemment, tout le monde a décroché quoi.
On s'est dit : ça nous intéresse plus. Oui, ça nous intéresse plus quoi. Il y a un côté, on a perdu beaucoup de citoyens, les politiques ont perdu beaucoup de citoyens à ce moment-là.
C'est aussi à ce moment-là que commence à grandir le PTB, très fort au sud du pays, en particulier parce qu'il a dénoncé le cirque politique.
Plus que pour avoir été marxiste, aussi, mais d'abord parce qu'ils ont dénoncé le cirque politique. C'est l'acte fondateur, quelque part, du PTB nouveau.
Oui, oui. Et antipolitique. Antipolitique actuellement, comme elle se fait maintenant, en tout cas. Et je pense que dans les médias, on a eu aussi un retour de flamme quoi, de...
C'est trop. Il faut se détacher un peu de ça et continuer à suivre évidemment les faits, nous, journalistes, mais peut-être pas, en prenant, que ça prenne autant de place quoi, parce que-
Tu dirais trop de sensationnalisme ? Je me souviens qu'il y avait beaucoup de, on affichait en grand au JT le nombre de jours sans gouvernement, des trucs comme ça.
Oui, mais ça me paraît pas être le problème. Non, c'était plutôt toute une série de sujets sur les claquages de portes, sur un tel machin.
Et en fait, autant évidemment, on doit suivre, parce qu'on ne peut pas dire : on ferme les portes et on laisse les politiques négocier et plus personne ne regarde rien.
Ben non, on est journaliste, on est là pour aller justement voir ce qui se passe derrière les portes. C'est des dossiers importants qui se négocient quand même.
On parle de financement de la Sécu, etc. Enfin, je veux dire, attends.
Non, c'est plutôt dans notre manière de,
de s'intéresser à des micro-faits quoi, des choses qui sont
au fond pas si importantes, telle petite déclaration, telle provoque, tel machin, qui sont faites pour influencer le processus de négociation en fait, hein, pour faire avancer la cause de mon parti.
Je vais dire que untel veut augmenter le diesel. Hop ! Ah ben voilà, ça fait un petit sujet sur : il veut augmenter le diesel.
Ben non, je veux pas augmenter le diesel. Je vous donne un exemple vrai, qui s'est passé. Mais en fait, la mesure était là pour mettre en difficulté l'autre parti.
Et ça, on doit pas faire.
On était plus dans love story que dans-
Oui, voilà.
Que dans sensation.
Et en fait, on est manipulé, nous, journalistes, alors. Vous voyez ? Parce qu'on est, forcément, quand on nous donne une information, le parti qui nous donne une information, c'est parce qu'il pense qu'il a intérêt à ce que ça sorte.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on doit pas la prendre. On doit la prendre, on doit la faire nôtre pour essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe, mettre ça avec d'autres, mais pas la sortir pour sortir, faire vivre le feuilleton, si vous voulez.
C'est pas ça qu'on doit faire. C'est pas un feuilleton, c'est pas une série télé quoi. Donc, on doit comprendre ce qui se passe pour pouvoir l'expliquer aux gens, aux auditrices et aux auditeurs,
mais pas le moins du monde essayer de se laisser manipuler.
Et dans ces longues crises, on est quand même, et je parle des journalistes en général, pas moi, pas la RTBF, pas La Libre, pas Le Soir, peu importe.
On est un peu vite les jouets, si vous voulez, des partis qui, en négociation, savent exactement ce qui se passe autour de la table.
C'est des lieux justement fermés. Donc, ils nous racontent du off, ils nous disent pas tout. Donc, il faut être beaucoup plus humble.
En fait, nous ne savons pas très bien ce qui se passe. Et donc, si on ne sait pas très bien ce qui se passe, n'en parlons pas trop ou alors seulement si on est sûr et certain et qu'on a fait un travail vraiment profond.
Mais c'est pas au jour le jour qu'on s'est fait un travail profond. C'est après quelques semaines qu'on s'est dit : voilà ce qui s'est passé.
Avec le recul, oui.
Bien sûr.
Le recul, du coup, sur le Covid ?
Moi, alors, le Covid, c'était très intéressant, très stressant.
Ça met des contraintes aussi, juste logistiquement. La distance avec les micros, ce genre de trucs.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, oui.
Les interviews, les, comment ça, Egbert Lachaert qui tombe malade, ce genre de choses.
Oui, oui, oui. En même temps, c'était une expérience stressante parce que, on était au contact au tout début, en particulier avec les autorités, les virologues, épidémiologistes, etc.
Qui étaient très inquiets, vraiment très inquiets. Ça, je crois que c'est quelque chose que peut-être,
quand on est loin du pouvoir, et c'est normal, on comprend mal parce que les gens de pouvoir, s'ils viennent à la télévision, etc.
Ils doivent donner une impression de sécurité, de maîtrise des choses. Ils peuvent pas apparaître comme : écoutez, on ne sait pas, c'est le bordel.
En off, c'était quand même la panique. Donc,
moi, je voyais ça. Et effectivement, je crois pas qu'on se rend compte à quel point on est passé près d'une situation qu'a eue l'Italie dans le nord
Donc vraiment un débordement complet de nos hôpitaux avec des camions militaires qui viennent chercher les cadavres.
Enfin, c'était vraiment terrible. Y avait beaucoup de médecins, et cetera, qui me disaient : « On va vers ça, là, très vite et ça ne va pas, on ne décide pas ce qu'il faut.
» Et puis tout d'un coup, à retard un peu, mais pas trop de retard, mais un peu trop quand même.
Heureusement, ça aurait pu aller encore plus mal, mais le politique a décidé du confinement et on l'a fait comme tous les autres, parce que sinon, c'était le débordement.
Fermeture des bars, puis fermeture des parcs et puis voilà.
Le premier confinement. Alors le deuxième, c'était de la folie quoi. Parce que la deuxième, là, par contre, on savait.
On avait eu l'expérience de l'épidémiologie, on sait. On sait que à peu près telle courbe, ben les hôpitaux dans quinze jours vont se retrouver débordés.
On le sait parce que l'épidémiologie avait l'expérience de la vague, du virus, on savait comment il allait, et cetera.
Et puis là, on prend pas les décisions. En octobre 2020 ou 2021, j'ai oublié la date maintenant. Mais ça, donc, quand, à la fin de l'été, quoi, à la fin du premier confinement où on se libère un peu.
Il y a un facteur électoraliste, effectivement, dans le fait d'annoncer à la population : « Bon, on vous a libéré, mais en fait, finalement... »
Ben c'est pas électoraliste parce que y avait pas d'élection à venir vraiment directement, mais c'était un manque de courage, là.
Vraiment, il y a eu un manque de courage. Je dis très peu ça parce que le manque de courage, c'est vite ce qu'on dit : « Oh, ils sont pas courageux, les politiques ».
Mais là, il y a eu un manque d'anticipation et de courage à dire : « Voilà, malheureusement, les chiffres montent, on est à la sortie de l'été, il va falloir retourner en confinement.
» Et on a attendu tellement avant de le dire qu'on a dû prendre des mesures extrêmes. Et c'était la fameuse bulle de un, c'était tous les bars fermés, et cetera.
Est-ce que tu dirais que Frank Vandenbroucke a été courageux à ce moment-là ?
Oui.
Parce que lui, effectivement, il a plutôt tendance à dire : « Faut pas déconner ».
Oui, il a été courageux à ce moment-là.
Et heureusement, il avait des gens-
Je dis pas qu'il a toujours bien fait dans la crise, mais à ce moment-là, c'était octobre 2020, hein. Oui, c'est le deuxième confinement, c'est lui qui suit.
Le premier qui était au printemps 2020, donc celui de l'octobre. Là, il a été courageux, oui. Lui et De Croo, d'ailleurs.
Et après, il y en a eu d'autres qui ont été courageux, hein, c'est pas ça, mais dans les politiques, c'est ceux qui, je pense, et heureusement, ils étaient ministres de la Santé.
Mais donc, ce que tu retiens dans les coulisses, c'est un petit peu cette hésitation, ce : « En fait, je gère pas du tout le dossier. »
Non. Oui, alors, et c'est aussi, comme disait Jürgen Habermas, philosophe allemand : « La lumière crue de l'incertitude ».
On était, tout était dans l'incertitude. On ne savait pas. Et encore une fois, les politiques, quand ils viennent en plateau télé, ils ne peuvent pas avoir l'air de ne pas savoir quoi faire.
C'est impossible, parce que sinon, ils créent la panique. C'est pire que mieux. Donc même si, je veux pas dire qu'ils doivent mentir, mais ils doivent faire au moins semblant de maîtriser les choses, quoi.
Ils peuvent pas arriver en disant : « Écoutez, on ne sait pas du tout, c'est la merde. » Non, ça, ils peuvent pas.
Quand on voit ce qui se passe derrière, effectivement, là, on se dit quand même que, au contraire, c'est pas une critique contre eux, au contraire.
Je crois que si on veut bien les comprendre, qu'ils étaient dans un faisceau de, dans une situation tellement difficile et surtout incertaine, parce qu'avec le recul, on se dit : « Oui, mais on savait ça, on savait ça.
» Au tout début, il y a tellement de choses qu'on ne savait pas et sur lesquelles on a dû agir, qui a rendu vraiment extrême la décision politique.
Et c'était très intéressant à observer. Il y a beaucoup de gens, Sophie Wilmès et d'autres, Frank Vandenbroucke, qui se sont bien sortis, quoi, qui, à un moment donné, ont réussi à quand même,
voilà, montrer qu'ils étaient des hommes et des femmes politiques de qualité, quoi.
Dernier épisode que j'ai retenu sur ces vingt dernières années, c'est la montée de la N-VA au pouvoir pour la première, la unique fois au fédéral.
Donc 2014. Très rapide, hein, pour le coup. On avait l'habitude, enfin, on commençait à avoir l'habitude de crises politiques beaucoup plus longues.
Je vais te laisser commenter, mais selon moi, je me rappelle, c'est qu'il y avait effectivement un biais de nouveau francophone de : « Oh, la N-VA, c'est l'adversaire ».
Mhm.
Comment est-ce que tu le retiens, toi ?
Oui, il y a eu un peu cet effet-là aussi. Je suis d'accord sur la N-VA et sur la manière dont on la considérait dans les médias, qui n'existait pas, par exemple, au moment de la Volksunie, l'ancêtre de la N-VA.
Bon, c'est pas considéré comme ça. Voilà, c'était pas un problème de les interroger, c'était pas un problème de faire des gouvernements avec eux.
On l'a déjà fait plusieurs fois, des réformes de l'État avec eux. Effectivement, la N-VA est restée incomprise par beaucoup de francophones, mais il y avait quand même des raisons à cela.
C'est que, et c'est la stratégie de Weyts dès 2005, avec ces fameux camions remplis d'argent qui arrivent à l'ascenseur de Strépy-Thieu.
C'est de la provoc. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est provoqué ? On réagit. Et c'est évidemment ce qu'il ne faut pas faire.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui, ça paraît évident. Si vous êtes, par exemple, sur les réseaux sociaux, sur Twitter, sur Facebook, quelqu'un vous provoque, ne lui répondez pas.
Sinon, vous alimentez la bête, quoi. Surtout du côté des journalistes. Les politiques font ce qu'ils veulent, ma foi. Mais du côté journaliste, on aurait dû être un peu plus-
Je retiens cette phrase et je vais te la renvoyer dans quelques instants. Pour, voilà, pour enchaîner donc là sur, voilà, ces cinq événements que j'ai retenus sur ces vingt dernières années.
J'ai ici une quote. La source n'est pas la meilleure, mais comme je t'ai dit, c'est pas facile de faire des recherches sur toi.
La source, c'est Alain Destexhe, qui te prête des propos. Alors, je lis ici que quand tu interviewais un certain Drieu Godefridi, lui te faisait remarquer apparemment que 90 % des journalistes américains étaient de gauche.
Et toi, tu lui as répondu : « Il n'y a pas de problème du moment que ces journalistes restent objectifs ».
Oui.
Alors, est-ce que tu valides cette quote ? Est-ce que Alain Destexhe n'a pas déformé tes propos ?
Je ne sais pas. Je ne sais plus si je l'ai dit, mais je pourrais le redire maintenant. Donc, moi, y a pas de souci.
Tu crois à l'objectivité comme étant une possibilité pour un journaliste ?
Exactement. Je pense que c'est jamais un fait. Nous ne le sommes jamais, mais si on abandonne cet idéal d'objectivité, alors on n'est plus journaliste.
Ça, je crois que c'est impossible. C'est-à-dire que-
C'est un objectif, mais pas une réalité.
C'est un idéal, c'est un horizon du métier. Je crois que sans cet horizon-là, on est perdu, on est déboussolé, vraiment.
Parce que ce que j'ai dit là, 90 % des journalistes américains sont de gauche. Que sais-je ? C'est lui qui dit ça.
J'en sais rien. Et puis de gauche.
C'est un biais, disons.
Puis de gauche pour qui ?
Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Pour Godefridi, je ne m'étonne pas que 90 % des journalistes soient de gauche. Je me demande pourquoi il est pas 99 % d'ailleurs.
C'est 99 à mon avis. Non, mais ça dépend toujours. Et pourquoi pas de droite ? Je connais des marxistes sensés qui me disent : « Vous savez, tous les journalistes sont de droite, hein ».
Pour des marxistes qui croient dans la lutte des classes, bien sûr, tous les journalistes sont de droite.
Sur la question de l'objectivité du journalisme, certains défendraient plutôt l'idée de, mais donc comme c'est un horizon inatteignable-
Mh.
Assumons nos biais, assumons notre position dans le monde, assumons le fait qu'on a été formés, sculptés-
Bien sûr.
Par, voilà, différents événements, différentes sensibilités philosophiques.
Oui oui.
Et revendiquons-le.
Mais oui, mais c'est ça que je dis. Je pense que moi, ça me dérange pas du tout. Je lis beaucoup de journalistes qui s'assument conservateurs, des journalistes qui s'assument marxistes ou des gens de gauche et qui sont journalistes.
Donc moi, j'ai pas de problème à ce qu'on s'assume, mais je pense qu'ils peuvent dire ça parce qu'ils gardent un idéal d'objectivité.
Alors c'est quoi l'idéal d'objectivité ? Puisqu'on n'y arrive pas. Bien sûr, personne n'est tout à fait neutre, on naît avec des valeurs dans un milieu, etc. Bien sûr.
Et donc je suis pas idéaliste, encore une fois, quand je dis ça, mais à mon avis, ce qui se passe, c'est Raymond Aron qui le disait, donc
important philosophe français, quand on parlait de la neutralité du sociologue, mais ça vaut pour le journaliste.
Il disait : « Bah non, effectivement, personne n'est tout à fait neutre, mais par contre, il faut se garder de sélectionner arbitrairement les faits ».
C'est ça en fait l'objectivité. C'est-à-dire, vous ne pouvez pas passer sous silence des faits que vous voyez, simplement parce qu'ils n'arrangent pas votre vision du monde.
Mh.
Alors effectivement, on est à gauche, on fait une enquête par exemple qui va plus porter sur les plus faibles de la société.
C'est normal, c'est votre orientation de gauche. Vous allez vous intéresser à ça. Les journalistes plutôt à droite vont aller voir des entrepreneurs qui ont réussi.
Ça dérange pas. Chacun va, vous voyez, avec ses inclinaisons, aller choisir des sujets qui l'intéressent. Ça, c'est normal.
Mais quand il va faire ce sujet-là, il ne peut pas passer sous silence arbitrairement des faits. C'est ça en fait.
Mh.
Moi, je continue donc à penser que bien sûr, le journalisme et l'engagement, c'est possible et c'est pas du tout un problème dans le métier, mais à condition de garder une certaine valeur de vérité, c'est-à-dire donner une valeur à la,
au fait de récolter des faits.
C'est la définition même d'un fait, c'est l'objectivité du fait. Le fait est là, il est partageable.
Croiser ses sources-
Croiser ses sources, c'est les méthodes, c'est les procédures. Et puis ne pas sélectionner les faits qui nous arrangent.
C'est pas que de dire la vérité, parce qu'on peut dire un fait tout à fait exact, mais oublier tout à fait les autres. Par exemple, un homme politique, vous allez dire quelque chose sur lui qui est tout à fait vrai.
Vous allez évidemment pas dire qu'il est corrompu. Bah si vous le savez. Mais non, mais c'est vrai. Si vous le savez, si vous avez des faits de corruption, vous devez les donner.
C'est ça. Même un journaliste de gauche qui adore un homme politique de gauche ou l'inverse de droite, qui adore un politique de droite, s'il est au courant de faits de corruption, il doit les donner.
Et dans ce sens-là, c'est parce qu'il est fidèle à son souci. Alors, on peut sortir les grands mots, l'impartialité, etc.
Qui sont toujours des idéaltypes, des horizons qu'on ne peut pas abandonner sous peine, à mon avis alors, d'être totalement dans le, allez, le relativisme.
Chacun sa vérité, chacun ses faits. Au fond, c'est ça alors. Si on sort de l'objectivité, c'est chacun ses faits.
Mais reste-
Les faits alternatifs, on y est.
Ouais, ouais.
Bah voilà.
Encore une notion intéressante. Reste alors à définir, dans cette notion que tu viens d'exprimer, qu'est-ce que c'est l'objectivité ?
Oui.
Et certains, certaines, voilà, je pense par exemple à une ancienne journaliste que j'ai interviewée,
qui a un certain profil militant, voilà, qui est Alice Coffin et qui, elle, dit : « L'objectivité, c'est la subjectivité de l'ordre établi des dominants ».
Classique du journalisme néomarxiste quoi.
Ok.
Oui, oui, mais ça, je suis pas d'accord.
Parce que effectivement, si vous voulez, les notions d'objectivité comme les notions de liberté aussi, ou d'intérêt général, ou des choses comme ça par exemple,
sont critiquées par toutes sortes de marxistes en ce sens que ce serait une manière de justifier ou de légitimer l'ordre dominant.
Effectivement, depuis Marx, c'est la critique du libéralisme selon Marx ou une partie. C'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça, mais en tout cas, c'est vrai qu'il y a des éléments comme ça chez Marx.
Or, je pense qu'il n'a pas tout à fait tort. Souvent, ces notions ont servi d'argument d'autorité quelque part.
Mh.
Contre les intérêts des classes. Je termine là-dessus, les classes les plus défavorisées, certainement au XIXᵉ siècle, etc.
Donc il faut un retour critique sur ces notions-là. Mais le retour critique ne nous oblige pas à nous en passer. Encore une fois, moi, je ne sais pas comment un journaliste peut faire son métier,
même engagé, en disant : « Tout ce qui passe passe par moi.
Je suis une personne subjective, etc. Donc je peux écrire ce que je veux ». Non, pas écrire ce que je veux. Je dois me conformer aux faits.
Je pense que on a—
À la réalité, ça veut dire l'objectivité.
De réalité, de déontologie, d'objectivité.
Oui, oui.
Je ne pense pas que, par exemple, elle n'est pas dans cette pièce, mais je ne pense pas qu'une Alice Coffin défend l'idée qu'il faut abandonner la déontologie, qu'il faut faire des faits alternatifs, des choses comme ça.
Je pense simplement que effectivement, on entend souvent ce mot « objectivement » employé comme argument d'autorité.
Oui.
Façon de dire, il n'y a pas d'autre façon de penser en fait.
Ah oui, non, non, bien sûr, mais c'est pas dans ce sens-là que je l'entends. C'est plutôt objectivité comme la—
Factuelle.
La possibilité de découvrir et de reconnaître ensemble des faits.
Mh.
Les faits sont là, on les reconnaît ensemble. Pour reconnaître ensemble un fait, donc quelque chose qui semble évident, un fait évident.
Il y a aujourd'hui, ici, un enregistreur sur la table. Bien, c'est parce que nous reconnaissons que nos deux subjectivités, si vous voulez, nos deux peuvent s'unir sur un tiers qui est une réalité.
Ce tiers, c'est l'objectivité. Ce qui permet de se mettre d'accord, c'est une certaine notion commune qui est l'objectivité.
Alors après, évidemment, nous sommes toujours subjectifs dans notre manière de partager ça, mais c'est une subjectivité qui ne vient pas de nulle part.
Nous partageons les mêmes catégories, si vous voulez, dans notre manière d'appréhender le monde et donc nous pouvons quand même nous mettre d'accord sur des réalités.
Sinon, encore une fois, je crois qu'alors le risque, c'est le relativisme et les faits alternatifs.
Mh.
Au fond, vous, journalistes de gauche, vous avez vos faits. Moi, journaliste de droite, j'ai mes faits.
Ouais.
Vous voyez ?
Et donc, si on veut reconnaître des faits ensemble, alors je ne vois pas comment on peut faire. On peut appeler ça autrement que l'objectivité.
Si vous préférez parler d'impartialité.
Ouais.
Au fond, on en revient toujours à la même chose. C'est une relation à la vérité. C'est ça que ça veut dire. On ne peut pas abandonner l'idée de vérité quand on est journaliste.
Alors, on peut dire : « Oui, mais la vérité, ça n'existe pas ». Tout à fait. D'accord. Les faits. Ok, vous remplacez vérité, parfait.
Mais c'est quoi les faits ? C'est le rapport honnête à la réalité. Donc c'est la vérité. Donc on n'en sort jamais. C'est ça que je veux dire.
Il y a le traitement des faits.
Mh.
Et puis il y a le traitement des opinions. Et par exemple—
Oui.
On peut imaginer. Bon, je dis imaginer, mais en fait, c'est des interviews que j'ai pu écouter.
On peut imaginer un journaliste qui s'adresse à Bart Oliver et qui dit : « Pensez-vous toujours que les écolos doivent aller en enfer ? »
Mh.
Bon, ça c'est très partiel—
C'est un jugement de valeur, oui.
C'est très, très orienté. On n'est pas tellement dans la notion de établir les faits ou se mettre d'ac— croiser nos subjectivités, etc.
Il y a une subjectivité, un angle, une partialité qui est présente. Et pourquoi ne pas la reconnaître ?
Pourquoi ne pas assumer de dire : bon, on est quand même un journal de droite ici.
Oui, oui, oui, oui. Mais ça, ça ne me dérangera pas. Je lis— alors tout ce qu'ils écrivent n'est pas excellent.
Mais par exemple, De Ounderbrak, un journal numérique essentiellement, je sais pas s'ils publient encore en papier, nationaliste flamand, je lis et il y a des choses très intéressantes là-dedans.
Non, non, moi, j'ai pas de souci par rapport à ça, qu'on oriente ses questions en fonction de sa—
pas sur le service public, à mon avis, parce que nous, on a d'autres charges, mais que des journalistes engagés orientent leurs questions ne me dérange pas du tout.
Ok.
Non, non, c'est dans la manière dont,
dont on va évoquer encore une fois les faits. Si je fais une interview de Bart De Wever autour de ces questions-là, sur la nationalité flamande, comment il veut le rendre nécessaire, etc.
Et que j'oblitère volontairement,
parce que je suis convaincu de certaines choses,
certains faits ou certains éléments, je n'interroge pas Bart De Wever, par exemple, sur une grave affaire, je ne sais pas moi, il n'en a pas eu, mais ou sur une phrase, voilà, qui a choqué récemment,
ou sur des malversations que sais-je.
Enfin, peu importe, des éléments qui sont là, à mon avis, je manque à mon devoir de journaliste, même si je suis de gauche.
Oui, oui.
Voilà, c'est dans ce sens-là.
Voilà, tout à fait. Donc—
Et ça, je reviens là-dessus, mais l'honnêteté, c'est toujours par rapport à un certain sens de la réalité. Donc encore une fois, je pense qu'on ne peut pas se passer de la vérité, donc de l'objectivité.
Ok. Ben donc, on est largement d'accord. Je pense qu'il y a quelques notions sémantiques sur, voilà, réalité, objectivité, déontologie, etc.
Mais c'est pas un truc qui vient d'en haut, ça, c'est certain.
Oui, oui. Dernière question là-dessus. Est-ce que si, voilà, on peut, pas dans le public, mais dans le privé, revendiquer ou assumer, voilà, un certain
partialisme, une prise de position, un journalisme engagé, est-ce qu'il faut alors l'afficher, l'expliciter ?
Oui.
Dire clairement : ici, c'est plutôt à droite, ici, c'est plutôt à gauche.
Mais oui, mais par exemple, ZIN TV, vous voyez, ce média de gauche l'assume. Et ça me— je regarde souvent ce qu'ils font.
C'est très bien. Enfin, je dis pas que tout est bien, j'ai pas tout vu, mais j'ai vu plein de choses très intéressantes chez eux.
Ça me dérange pas. Et j'ai déjà lu des publications plus à droite, voilà, Journal du médecin, des trucs comme ça, des éditos, des ma... Et c'est,
c'est généralement affiché. Ici, ce qu'on fait à la RTBF, et moi, en particulier dans mes éditos, je ne l'affiche pas parce que mon ambition, c'est justement de pas,
défendre un argumentaire de ce qui sont mes convictions ou mes valeurs politiques.
Et tu penses que c'est possible ?
Oui, je pense que c'est possible parce que je pars pas de mes convictions, je pars plutôt des faits, je pars plutôt des éléments d'observation de la vie politique et je garde bien pour moi mes convictions sur les grandes idées politiques.
Je ne dis jamais : il faut réformer les pensions comme ça. Je ne dis jamais : il faut traiter l'immigration comme ça. Je ne dis jamais ça.
En fait, moi, là où je prends des positions, c'est plutôt sur la manière de faire de la politique. Si on a dit une telle chose et que deux semaines plus tard, on dit autre chose, je le pointe.
Vous voyez, c'est plutôt ces éléments-là.
Tu vas éventuellement exprimer le fait qu'une idée peut—
Être incohérente.
Être incohérent ou être, ouh là, ouf, ouf, c'est, voilà qui est très surprenant.
Mais tu ne vas pas émettre un jugement de valeur en disant—
Voilà. Je vais pas dire voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire.
Quelle piètre idée.
Ça, je ferais jamais.
Ouais. On parlait donc de, par exemple, des réseaux sociaux. On parlait du fait que c'est pas forcément une bonne idée de répondre à la provocation.
Non.
On va imaginer une situation, par exemple, où un politicien très adepte de Twitter, imaginons, commente très régulièrement ton travail compulsivement en disant que ton travail, c'est de la blague, que monsieur Henne écrit et dit n'importe quoi.
Il accuse la RTBF d'avoir un agenda. Et on imaginerait, par exemple, que tu lui réponds de se calmer.
Mh.
Donc, ce qui n'est pas tout à fait cohérent avec ce que tu disais tout à l'heure sur le fait d'éviter de répondre à la provocation.
Bien sûr.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour gérer une situation où un politicien et toi et la RTBF et ta rédaction entretiennent des relations tendues, voilà, en fonction des moments ?
Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour ensuite couvrir ça journalistiquement ? Et voilà, tu parlais d'un certain détachement, rester factuel, etc.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour faire la part des choses ?
Mais d'abord, j'ai pu, moi, au début de Twitter, répondre un peu. J'ai appris de ça.
C'était il y a pas si longtemps.
Oui, oui.
2021, je crois.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. C'est les dernières fois. Après, j'ai définitivement arrêté. Je ne réponds plus jamais à aucune provocation, que ce soit de politique ou une autre.
Et depuis Musk, c'est devenu absolument l'enfer.
Parce que c'est le but même de Twitter, en particulier, de susciter ce genre de provocations. C'est un réseau qui n'est absolument pas fait pour susciter une vraie conversation ou une discussion ou un échange.
C'est fait pour clasher et provoquer. Donc ça ne sert à rien. Donc j'ai arrêté complètement. Et donc, vous me demandiez, enfin, tu me demandais la manière dont je traite ça.
Je ne réponds pas. Je m'en fous. Objectivement, je m'en fous. Et dès qu'il y a quelqu'un qui me provoque, je bloque.
Parce que voilà, comme ça, j'ai pas de problème.
Mais donc, pour revenir sur la question du—
Et comment on fait pour travailler avec ?
Cet éventuel politicien avec ceux qui voudraient couvrir médiatiquement alors que c'est tendu.
Après, moi, j'ai, voilà, j'ai des politiques à qui je ne parle pas.
Oui.
Parce que je trouve qu'ils ont été—
Tu les as bloqués.
Non, oui, quelque part, je l'ai— c'est un peu comme Twitter, ben il suffit de ne pas répondre au téléphone, quoi.
Voilà, non, parce que je trouve qu'ils sont pas dignes de confiance et il y en a pas qu'un. Parce que simplement, voilà, il y a des gens qui
essayent de me dire des choses, de me mettre des messages dans l'oreille pour tenter de m'influencer, c'est bien normal, tout le monde le fait, mais qui mentent de manière excessive ou qui sont agressifs.
Ben moi, c'est simple. Maintenant, après vingt ans d'expérience, je ne réponds plus. J'ai pas besoin d'avoir des contacts avec tous les politiciens pour comprendre ce qui se passe dans ce pays.
Je peux me passer de certains si j'estime qu'en fait, la relation est toxique, quoi. Donc, moi, ceux qui vraiment ne me sont pas utiles ou qui sont excessifs, je discute plus avec eux, c'est pas intéressant.
Je sélectionne les gens utiles. Non non, je discute plus avec eux.
Et tu estimes que tu arrives à continuer ton travail—
Oui, oui.
À faire tes chroniques éditoriales—
Oui.
De manière—
Oui, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui discutent avec eux par ailleurs.
Distanciée.
On est une équipe ici.
Mh.
Donc on est beaucoup de journalistes au contact des politiques, on se parle souvent. Et donc, c'est, voilà, dans un parti, y a des centaines de personnes.
À la RTBF, y a plein de gens.
Notre compréhension des enjeux, heureusement d'ailleurs, je ne dois pas appeler Paul Magnette pour savoir ce qui se passe au PS quoi, ou je dois pas appeler Jean-Marc Nollet pour savoir ce qui se passe chez Écolo.
Je peux passer par d'autres sources, par des députés, par des militants, par des cadres du parti, enfin peu importe, pour essayer de comprendre.
Et donc voilà, je peux me passer de certains, peu importe, politiciens ou politiciennes, si j'estime que, en fait, ces gens sont vraiment dans un agenda offensif envers moi et qu'ils n'ont rien de bon à m'apporter.
Je préfère concentrer mon temps sur des gens utiles.
C'est, voilà, une transition intéressante. Tu parles d'agenda dans les relations entre journalistes et politiques.
Y a ce truc assez particulier au journalisme politique où les sujets des articles, les sujets de l'actualité sont aussi, en fait, vos sources.
Et dans, par exemple, dans des réunions fermées de négociation de formation de gouvernement ou dans le contexte du Covid, etc., sont des salles fermées avec quelques individus, quelques barons, quelques ministres.
Et va y avoir des fuites. Tel ou tel journaliste va être contacté, va recevoir un message, etc. Ça va se faire dans un contexte, comme tu le disais, d'un agenda.
Y a une idée derrière cette fuite. Comment est-ce qu'on gère, en fait, le fait de se dire : est-ce que je relaie, est-ce que je participe à ce qui apparaît clairement comme un agenda ?
Ou bien est-ce que je ne veux pas faire partie de, je ne veux pas être un outil dans les mains de ce politicien et relayer ce—
Il faut le faire de manière critique, évidemment hein, se dire : ben je sais, s'il me dit ça, c'est sans doute parce que, donc voilà, de manière critique.
Maintenant, moi, pour les chroniques, par exemple, je n'écris jamais quelque chose qui vient du off. Je ne dis jamais : Tiens, en off, on m'a dit que...
Ça, je ne fais jamais.
Oui, non, moi non plus.
Jamais. Voilà. Donc, je me sers du off pour comprendre, on me dit : Oh ben tiens, untel m'a dit ça. Ça me permet de comprendre les choses.
Mais je ne vais pas écrire quelque chose qu'on m'a dit en off. Évidemment, ça participe à plein de choses que je dois recouper pour comprendre une situation, mais c'est tout.
Quand je parle de fuite, je parle vraiment pas du off, mais d'un journaliste qui vraiment— un politicien qui vraiment aurait l'intention de faire une fuite et dit : Tiens, en fait, voilà ce qui se passe,
Oui, de manière critique, je crois qu'y a que ça. Se dire, voilà, quelle est l'importance de la fuite.
Bon évidemment, si c'est un élément déterminant, je ne sais pas moi, si on apprend dans une fuite, dans une négociation de gouvernement qu'on s'apprête à scinder la Sécu et qu'on a les textes qui le montrent,
on va le sortir parce que c'est quand même un truc qui concerne les 12 millions de Belges quoi.
Donc ça dépend de l'importance de la fuite, mais on sait toujours qu'on est dans un certain type de jeu et selon la fuite ou--
on a déjà pris des décisions ici, souvent dans la dernière négociation, 2019-2020, avec Thomas Gadisseux
et d'autres, mais notamment en discutant avec lui, des choses qu'on sait, qui sont sur la table, qu'on nous a données, on dit : on ne le sort pas.
On ne le sort pas parce que voilà, c'est un, on essaie de faire fuiter quelque chose pour faire foirer la négociation.
On n'est pas du tout sûr que ça va passer. Si ça tombe, ce truc va être abandonné. Parce que combien de pistes sont testées puis abandonnées dans les négociations ?
Des centaines. Donc pourquoi sortir celle-là plutôt qu'une autre ? Et donc attendons de voir bien ce qui se passe pour éventuellement la sortir, oui.
On est tr-- maintenant, on est prudents, beaucoup plus prudents qu'avant, d'ailleurs.
Mh. Je posais aussi la question de, voilà, la question éventuelle des tensions entre journalistes et politiciens au niveau personnel, parce que j'ai moi-même une expérience compliquée avec un politicien en particulier.
Peut-être que c'est le même, qui, voilà, lorsqu'il a souhaité venir dans le podcast de son propre chef, tout d'un coup, en pleine interview, s'est mis à
attaquer en fait des consœurs journalistes qui sont aussi des amies et a expliqué qu'elles sont des ennemis de la démocratie.
Et là, je me suis retrouvé dans un malaise profond
et à me demander : OK, est-ce que je prends une décision éditoriale et je dis : ben non, je sais que je suis biaisé parce que c'est ma pote, mais je vais couper parce que je sais que c'est pas vrai.
Ou bien est-ce que je me dis : ben non, voilà le discours de ce politicien et voilà sa conviction profonde vis-à-vis de l'état, l'état de ce qui nous divise dans notre société.
Et donc je le laisse. J'étais dans un malaise profond. Est-ce que t'as déjà été dans des situations comme celle-là ?
Oui. Ben, c'est-à-dire j'ai fait dix ans d'interviews, donc des invectives en direct sur des-- alors pas nécessairement sur des collègues, mais sur des politiques, oui.
Je me souviens d'une fois, par exemple, où Philippe Moreau, décédé maintenant, était venu dire d'un reportage de la RTBF sur Molenbeek et la manière dont il gérait notamment l'action des,
des immigrés à Molenbeek, des minorités, c'était, il avait dit : Mais votre reportage, c'est digne de Goebbels.
Il suit comme ça là, le matin. Bon voilà, bon. Alors, je veux dire, qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Parce que argumenter, mais argumenter quoi ? Goebbels ? Enfin, c'est débile, évidemment. Donc je ne sais même plus comment s'est terminé l'interview.
Et je sais que les collègues qui avaient été visés par ça étaient assez fâchés. Et bon, de toute façon, il y a eu des réactions et puis voilà, les choses se sont faites et cette provocation s'est effondrée d'elle-même quoi.
Et le reportage était très bien fait et a surclassé la provoque de Philippe Moreau. Oui, donc ça m'est déjà arrivé.
C'est des situations vraiment très difficiles. C'est à ce moment-là qu'on souhaite parfois pouvoir arrêter les interviews.
Quand elles sont en direct, c'est plus dur. Cela dit, j'en vois quand même peu de politiques qui attaquent frontalement des journalistes dans des interviews en direct.
Ils le font généralement sur Twitter ou des choses comme ça.
Dans des livres, parfois.
Dans des livres, parfois, c'est vrai, oui. Mais enfin comparer, c'est toujours désagréable, mais comparer à ce qui se passe en France, aux États-Unis, on est quand même dans un autre monde ici en Belgique.
Je veux dire, la violence des relations entre le politique et les journalistes aux États-Unis ou en France atteint quand même des sommets par rapport à ce qui se passe ici en Belgique.
C'est de toute façon trop. Et moi-même, j'en ai été victime. Mon intégrité a déjà été, vous avez repris des trucs sur Twitter, a déjà été attaquée plusieurs fois.
Voilà, au début, je répondais, puis je réponds plus. Je pense qu'ils commencent à comprendre, ceux qui le font, que c'est inutile.
J'ai bon espoir d'ailleurs que ce soit un mouvement de pendule quoi, qui a un effet comme ça d'allers-retours, puis qu'on revienne à un peu de calme parce que c'est inefficace.
Et je vois que le mouvement un peu trumpiste, de monter la population contre les journalistes qui existait aux États-Unis n'arrive quand même pas à prendre ici en Belgique francophone, en tout cas ni flamande.
Très bonne question. C'était d'ailleurs le sujet de ta chronique ce matin sur le wokisme, entre guillemets. Chaque fois que je dois dire ce mot, ça me--
je sens un petit peu le vomir tellement c'est un concept assez attrait, assez trumpiste.
Question très rapide là-dessus. On a bientôt terminé l'entretien. J'écoutais Jon Stewart, qui a fait son retour dans le Daily Show aux États-Unis.
J'écoute pas beaucoup.
Ah voilà, mais j'adore Jon Stewart.
C'est juste le lundi, malheureusement, mais voilà. Et il commentait le fait que, par exemple, certaines figures de Fox News commençaient à dire beaucoup de bien de la Russie, de Vladimir Poutine.
Et un ancien visage de Fox News, Tucker Carlson, est carrément parti faire un reportage et une interview de Vladimir Poutine où il chante la gloire du métro à Moscou et des supermarchés.
La vie ici est formidable, vraiment. Si vous viviez ici, vous détesteriez les États-Unis. Enfin, ça allait assez loin dans le délire.
Et le commentaire de Jon Stewart, c'était de dire
qu'avant, on était dans la guerre froide, les tensions étaient intenses entre le bloc soviétique et le bloc américain
et qu'aujourd'hui, ben voilà, le capitalisme, le libéralisme dominent le monde et que la nouvelle scission, c'est woke versus pas woke.
Et c'est là-dessus qu'il y a le plus de tensions, le plus de divisions. C'est là-dessus que les campagnes électorales jouent, sur ce sentiment de-
Guerre culturelle.
Voilà, guerre culturelle, du sol qui disparaît sous nos pieds et on perd nos repères, etc. Est-ce que tu partages cette analyse de Jon Stewart ?
Alors, en tout cas, je remarque qu'il y a une tentative
que le clivage soit celui-là par une partie du spectre politique qui va de la droite conservatrice à l'extrême droite, parfois une droite démocratique aussi, c'est pas toujours le truc, mais effectivement, qu'il y ait une volonté de--
les clivages politiques ne sont pas figés.
Les divisions dans la société existent et les partis politiques ou toute une série de forces tentent de leur donner de la forme.
Clivage marxiste, les marxistes vont essayer de donner une certaine idée de ce qu'est le clivage entre classes. Voilà. Ils vont aussi quelque part inventer le clivage ou ils vont former l'opinion sur ce clivage-là.
Puis d'autres partis vont faire autrement. Et ici, on a vraiment une tentative claire d'un camp aux États-Unis, le camp républicain, le camp conservateur aux États-Unis, qui dépasse même le Parti républicain, d'imposer une lecture de ce clivage.
Le Vlaams Belang aussi en Belgique.
Oui, et qui récupère donc ces techniques américaines, mais c'est vrai que c'est une vieille histoire pour lui.
Oui, bien sûr, mais chaque parti-
Et le Rassemblement national en France aussi.
Voilà, tente de former le clivage.
On dit souvent, voilà, importé des États-Unis, mais à ce stade, c'est, oui, enfin, c'est, c'est...
Mais le wokisme comme terme pour-- avant, on appelait ça l'islamo-gauchisme. Maintenant, on appelle ça le wokisme et avant, on appelait ça le politiquement correct.
Mais voilà. Il y a eu des générations où la bien-pensance et des générations de termes qui habitent toujours la même chose.
C'est cette idée, pour reprendre le terme de Finkielkraut, qui est donc un conservateur démocrate, qui dit : La France n'est plus la France.
C'est-à-dire, il y a quelque chose qui ne permet plus de définir notre identité. Notre identité est menacée. Au fond, c'est ça.
On perd nos repères, comme il disait. Très bien. Oui, alors ces partis tentent de le faire. Est-ce que c'est ça la réalité de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la société ?
Mais en fait, moi, je ne le sais pas. Moi, en tant que journaliste, ce n'est pas à moi de le dire. J'observe que ces débats ont lieu.
Et c'est justement pour ça que Tucker Carlson n'est pas journaliste. Quand il va, en fait, parce qu'il n'a aucune volonté d'essayer de savoir ce que sont les faits.
Il y va avec ses convictions. Voilà, il n'a aucune-
Il sait parfaitement que les Russes ne touchent qu'un misérable salaire et qu'ils ne sont pas en mesure de vivre correctement.
Non, il n'en a rien à foutre des faits.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Donc voilà, je crois, encore une fois, on ne peut pas perdre de vue que notre idée, c'est d'essayer d'approcher les faits de manière objective.
Il n'y a rien à faire, de respecter les faits, de respecter la vérité. On ne peut pas s'en sortir.
On parlait tout à l'heure du fait que le public se désintéresse de plus en plus de la politique, que c'est, voilà, les histoires de BHV, ces histoires de négociation de budget, etc.
J'interviewais il y a quelques mois Thomas Dermine, qui a fait donc un livre sur les rapports entre Wallonie et Flandre.
Livre qui, donc, si tu l'as lu, très chiffré, beaucoup de notes en bas de page et beaucoup de références à des données statistiques, à des niveaux de vie, pouvoir d'achat, etc., etc., etc.
Et je lui ai remarqué : Mais tiens, est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, ce qui ne provoque pas le plus d'excitation dans le paysage politique, le plus de pathos, le plus d'émotion, c'est pas justement les questions de, voilà, les chiffrés budgétaires, etc.
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas plutôt, ben le on ne peut plus rien dire, le wokisme, l'anti-ter, le zwarte piet, etc.
En termes de pathos et d'émotion, je suis assez d'accord avec toi. Je crois que c'est ça qui-
Et donc d'engagement.
Et donc potentiellement d'engagement, effectivement. C'est pour ça que les partis sont, enfin, certains partis tentent d'aller là-dessus.
Voilà, oui, non, ça, je le remarque aussi. Et avec cette idée donc, qu'il y a une perte, il y a un déclin. Et ça, je crois que c'est vraiment très dangereux.
C'est-à-dire que les idées déclinistes ont toujours été les canaris dans la mine des idées autoritaristes.
C'est-à-dire, si on pense qu'on est en déclin, si on pense qu'on est en train de se fourvoyer complètement
Et que cette idée-là circule, qu'on va de mal en pis, c'est là qu'on a une opinion qui est prête à abandonner ce qu'elle a de plus précieux, quoi, sa liberté pour se sortir du déclin.
Ça, je crois vraiment que c'est dangereux. L'histoire l'a montré à plusieurs reprises. Le déclin, c'est vraiment une technique arrivée à maîtriser le déclin pour imposer des points de vue autoritaristes ou antidémocrates.
Moi, je ne crois pas du tout au déclin. Il y a évidemment des choses qui ne vont pas du tout. Mais on peut pas prendre des heures pour montrer qu'il y a des choses qui marchent mieux.
Le droit des homosexuels, enfin, tout, pour plein de choses quoi. Enfin, voilà. Et en fait, la discussion n'aurait pas de sens parce que vous prendrez chaque fois, vous, des choses qui vont moins bien, moi, des choses qui vont mieux.
Et puis on pourrait s'en sortir comme ça sans se dire... Et donc le déclin, c'est pas tellement des faits, c'est un récit, c'est un narratif.
Mais basé sur quoi, en fait ? Basé sur toute une série de faits qu'on sort et qu'on isole d'autres faits de manière arbitraire pour donner corps à un récit, à un narratif.
Et ça, le récit et le narratif, c'est des groupes de pression, des gens qui sont convaincus, des militants. Il n'y a pas de réalité de ça.
C'est matrixé, oui.
Ben, c'est-à-dire que le journaliste ne peut pas prendre position en disant : « C'est vrai, il y a un déclin ». Non, non, c'est un récit, c'est un narratif.
C'est, c'est-- on ne doit pas participer ni à ce narratif-là, ni au narratif marxiste d'ailleurs. Enfin, je veux dire dans les deux sens.
Nous, on doit essayer de rester au maximum sur la réalité des faits et leur donner du sens. Et c'est pas le fait de valider une lecture du monde qui est une lecture tout à fait politique, qui a sans doute ses raisons d'être.
Encore une fois, la lecture marxiste aussi. Mais nous, notre rôle, c'est pas celui-là, quoi. Et je pense que c'est
là que certains journalistes peuvent un peu, comme Tucker Carlson, etc., croire qu'ils peuvent être utiles à la population en se rangeant quelque part du côté des convictions et du côté-- en assumant pleinement une politique alors que-
Déjà, journaliste Tucker Carlson, on va-
Oui, oui, on peut se séparer. Oui, oui, on peut séparer.
Dans son cas, c'est surtout par opportunisme, puisque je pense que maintenant, il a un patron-
Oui, oui, oui, bien sûr, c'est aussi pour l'argent.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
C'est comme ça.
Mais bon, j'arrête pas de dire qu'on approche de la fin de l'entretien, mais la question donc du rôle du journalisme dans le, voilà, éviter de tomber dans le déclinisme, etc.
La ligne éditoriale d'une matinale, par exemple, sur La Première, c'est aussi un exercice de journalisme, un exercice de, de voilà, ben qui est-ce qu'on donne la parole dans le parti pris, etc.
C'est un exercice difficile. Ce n'est pas toi qui en as la charge, je pense.
C'est une équipe.
Voilà, c'est une équipe. Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, la ligne éditoriale de Matin Première est, selon toi, pluraliste ou biaisée dans le parti pris, on entend souvent le mot wokisme ?
Oh, écoute, on peut toujours trouver, dans un débat comme le parti pris qui est donc en plus, c'est deux personnes.
Est-ce que déjà, faudrait pas trop quatre ? Enfin, on peut touj- la configuration même du débat-
Il y a plusieurs duos.
Voilà, il y a plusieurs duos. On peut toujours sans doute trouver à redire. Et en fait, ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on évolue au cours du temps, au cours des saisons, on rajoute des personnes.
Par exemple, au début, on était parti dans l'idée, et on en est revenu, qu'on allait prendre des duos, puis ils allaient parler d'un petit peu de tout.
Maintenant, on a mis des duos thématiques. On a des duos qui sont plutôt juridiques, etc. Ce qui permet d'être beaucoup plus précis, d'être beaucoup plus juste.
Là, l'ambition, c'est d'avoir un débat sur les valeurs, un débat sur les lectures de la société qui peut s'échanger.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment plutôt le média comme plateforme qui permet de donner de la diversité des opinions.
Donc effectivement, on a une diversité d'opinions. On a des gens de gauche, on a des gens de droite, on a des femmes, on a des hommes, on a enfin voilà.
On essaye. Et c'est sûr que la représentation n'est pas parfaite et qu'on pourrait facilement nous dire : « Bah tiens, il manque de tel type de sensibilité » ou des choses comme ça.
Il faudrait sans doute alors pouvoir l'étendre. Maintenant, le problème, c'est que dans le dispositif, ben on a cinq jours, cinq duos, c'est vraiment difficile de pouvoir-
C'est un exercice compliqué.
Voilà, c'est un exercice compliqué, mais non, moi, je trouve pas qu'on entend trop le mot wokisme. Non, c'est un sujet.
Après, voilà, on a chacun nos opinions par rapport à ça. C'est un sujet qui fait débat et je pense que quand même, quand on en parle dans le parti pris, ça permet de déconstruire aussi certains mots, certaines choses de manière efficace.
Si on choisit de le faire.
Donc la toute dernière question, puisque voilà, cette fois, on va vraiment mettre fin à l'entretien. Je te remercie encore Bertrand.
On observe que beaucoup de figures connues du public reçoivent des offres de la part des partis pour devenir des têtes de liste.
Je pense à des Marc Isaï, à des Anne Delvaux, à des Jean-Claude Defossez, à des Olivier Marois. Je devine que tu as dû en recevoir des tonnes au fil des années.
Pourquoi est-ce que tu ne les as jamais acceptées ? Est-ce qu'un jour, tu les accepteras ?
Eh ben, j'ai jamais reçu.
Tu l'as jamais reçu ?
J'ai reçu pas mal de demandes d'emploi dans les entreprises privées ou dans des cabinets, etc. Voilà, même pas que lié à la politique, quoi.
Ça, j'ai reçu plusieurs fois dans ma carrière. Mais pour m'inscrire sur une liste, jamais.
Ah ouais, tiens.
Non, non.
Je suis très étonné.
Non, non. Jamais. Moi, ça m'étonne pas parce que d'abord, je crois qu'ils le savent, que ça m'intéresse pas.
Puisque voilà, Olivier Marois-
Non, mais je pense pas que c'est-
Tellement différent du tien.
D'abord, alors, il y a un truc.
Avec la télé, peut-être ?
Voilà. La radio, ma foi.
T'es plus un homme de radio.
La radio, ma foi, ça ne rapporte pas des voix, quoi. C'est ce qu'ils doivent se dire. Donc, ils cherchent-- généralement, quand ils font ça, ils cherchent de l'invisibilité, pas de la crédibilité.
Ils cherchent des gens visibles.
Julie Taton.
Voilà. Voilà, c'est des gens visibles.
NRJ, c'est de la radio. Julie Taton.
Oui, non, mais Julie Taton, elle a une image médiatique très forte parce qu'elle fait de la télé, etc. Oui, mais peu visible.
Tu mets ma tête sur une affiche, il y a pas la moitié, même pas, les-- 90 % des francophones qui reconnaissent qui c'est.
Puisque je suis une voix, quoi, plus qu'une visi-- Mais les partis cherchent de la visibilité quand ils font ça, quand ils vont chercher ces candidats.
Pas des gens crédibles. Donc, pour la visibilité, il y a mieux que moi, quoi. Voilà, je pense que c'est clair.
Donc, tu vas rester à la RTBF et on en est ravis.
Oui.
Merci beaucoup, Bertrand, pour ces un peu plus que septante minutes passées avec moi.
Et si ça tombe dans un an, je suis parti, quoi. Sur une liste.
Voilà, tout, tout ça, tout ça est sur la cassette.
Tout ça a été enregistré.
Je te remercie pour cet entretien et je te remercie aussi pour ton travail. Je suis très fidèle auditeur de tes chroniques et de L'Histoire continue aussi avec Hélène Maquet, le-
Tous les samedis.
Je te remercie pour la qualité de ton travail et je vous dis à très bientôt.
Merci de l'interview.
Au revoir.
Voilà, vous l'aurez compris, je suis très heureux de cet entretien avec Bertrand. C'est d'ailleurs la première et unique fois qu'il a fait un podcast format long en dehors de la RTBF et même le seul où il parle autant à la première personne.
J'espère que ça vous a plu. Vous pouvez évidemment retrouver ses chroniques matinales et son émission L'Histoire continue en duo avec Hélène Maquet, formidable Hélène Maquet, en podcast.
J'ai mis les liens en description. J'en profite aussi pour mentionner le fait que j'ai fait un passage télé dans l'émission Déclic de la RTBF, le même jour que mon interview avec Bertrand.
Voilà, j'en ai profité de mon passage à Reyers. C'était pour parler d'autisme. J'ai mis les liens en description. C'était terriblement court par contre, seulement neuf minutes.
J'ai même pas eu le temps de pluguer mon podcast. Mais voilà, je pense que j'ai réussi à faire passer le message et ça, c'est le principal.
Si vous découvrez Septante Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, n'hésitez pas à remonter dans le temps et à vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Vous pouvez écouter mon interview avec Alice Coffin d'ailleurs, si vous voulez un point de vue radicalement opposé. J'ai adoré cet épisode aussi, comme quoi je ne suis qu'amour.
Un grand merci à Mathieu pour son aide sur cet épisode et je vous dis à très bientôt.